Hannibal Montana,
is that it?
Montana will experience the Hannibal.
Montana will experience.
Can you get sued for that?
That too.
Or it's parody,
right?
Is Hannibal Montana Bowl bowls at the
end?
What is a Montana?
Both Montana Bill Rams is Ramsar
Hannibal.
What is Hannah Montana?
See this the show that a cute girl.
Cyrus girl,
right.
I hope they sued me to use the bump.
They can't win.
I can't win.
Right.
It's parody is.
Yeah.
It is not a mock usually just because I
think it's just a goofy thing.
Isn't that my Canadian thing?
Isn't that I'm not using any imagery.
I just think it's just funny words to
me.
Even if you were,
you know,
I think you're okay.
Whatever happened to that chick.
She was going crazy for awhile.
She a number.
She was grinding on people on TV.
The voice right now that's just started.
She said she wanted the judges or
something.
Hm.
She's talented girl.
You ever heard of talent?
She sang that song.
Jolene,
like that Dolly Parton Song.
I was like,
wow.
Like if she just sang shit like this,
she'd be goddamn gigantic.
If she changes to with transfer.
Really?
Yeah,
I think she saw that actress.
What have you seen her in her stuff?
She's been on Saturday night live.
Oh,
okay.
I thought you that.
Hannah Montana.
Hannah Montana back in [inaudible] eight
when I was.
I remember watching a couple of episodes
like this is all right.
Also my,
uh,
I used to be a dad fan fence who so
there used to be a dad fan fan fan.
Took too much heat,
man.
He did.
God Man.
I remember when dad fan was on last
comic standing because it was season one
and I was one of the judges and he
fucking killed.
Right.
And it didn't seem like there was
anything wrong what he was doing to me.
Yeah.
But a lot of people get mad at them just
for being.
No,
it was like they just thought he was
too,
uh,
too.
Too much of a big show.
You know,
he's too loud and I don't know what it
was.
If they got upset with him.
People like what they like.
People get angry,
people get angry at weird stuff.
People just get specifically angry.
Myself included,
but I don't share that for the Internet,
just angry amongst my friends and we
talk shit,
but I don't like to show that.
Right.
Like he'd get mad if your friend likes a
movie that sucked.
Yeah.
We'll just,
yeah.
Sometimes my friend,
my friend,
um,
didn't.
What was the movie with the,
uh,
with the moving shots?
Uh,
it was Zach Galifianakis is in it.
the Birdman Birdman.
Oh,
Zach.
Zach Galifianakis was in Burbank.
The stage director.
That's right.
Of course I met my friend Tony.
We would denver a toadie Turner.
My Dj,
he uh,
had wanted them.
We patches.
We in Denver for like four
days and he had a weed patch did you
could put on.
He got it from dispensary.
Uh,
and then he got high engine.
We started talking about Birdman.
Yeah.
Birdman.
He went on a 10 minute rant,
like fuck birdman movies.
Pretentious.
And he's just like,
man,
he was like,
I like Birdman,
but I don't know if I like it as much as
you hated it went on forever.
I couldn't believe it.
He's Kinda got a point.
It's kind of pretentious,
but I mean don't you want that sometimes
like someone to take a chance to make
something that's just bizarre.
There was a bizarre ass movie like that
was a chance to take a newbie and then.
Yeah,
they was,
I enjoyed it.
I'd never seen somebody be so passionate
about it.
Be around your friendly.
I didn't know you were a kid.
Hey,
people get like that with music.
Yeah.
You know,
you can talk to some people about
certain bands.
Just not supposed to.
Like,
like when I was a kid I used to have to
hide the fact that I loved kiss.
Yeah.
Because like when I was in like seventh
grade kiss was not cool.
I was like,
it was not a cool thing.
Like the young kids,
they won't,
they all wanted to know about like ACDC
and led Zeppelin.
So where,
uh,
when you were in seventh grade where was
kiss in their trajectory?
Here's what happened with kiss kiss had
this gigantic loyal following who came
to all their concerts.
They sold out gigantic arenas all over
the world,
but they couldn't get any radio play.
It was a real weird.
They only have like a couple of big hits
they have like bath.
Bath was a big hit.
Detroit rock city,
rock and roll all night.
Those were big in party every day.
That's still a big one,
but there wasn't a lot of radio play.
It was hard,
like there was a lot of bands that had
way more radio play,
but for whatever reason,
they never lost their popularity amongst
their hardcore fans because they put on
a great show.
I went to see them twice when they made
their comeback tour with Kevin James.
Kevin James was.
No,
no,
no.
We were friends.
We went to watch it.
Kevin.
Combination that would be doing some
standup up.
Have you ever done stand up in front of
a band?
Lots of times,
yeah.
Do you really?
Yeah.
Do you like it?
Sometimes.
Sometimes it can go.
Well,
you have to be set up correctly though,
and I've learned how to.
What's asked for to make this show go
right.
What's.
What do you ask for?
You just asked for somebody from the
band to introduce you.
Either onstage or off my and so you
establish in front of the crowd as a
friend of theirs and that just some
asshole that where the band says,
we booked this guy,
this guy,
please welcome Hannibal buress.
I learned that when I open for this
band,
it's cool.
Super Nice guys.
They saw me as Zane.
He's in Chicago,
the Chicago band,
a jam band.
Unfree Mcgee's a huge fan base.
They tour all the time and they asked me
to do this gig and the cow outside of
Chicago.
So excited to do it.
Just a couple hundred bucks or something
different gig opening for a band is cool
and it's packed.
Theater is packed.
And then uh,
they telling me that,
you know,
it's getting ready to go out and uh,
the lights drop and the crowd goes crazy
and I'm about to go home and that is not
for me at all.
And so then I just walk out and cold
like hello,
I'm Hannah.
And started trying to do comedy.
And people just like,
where's
unfreeze?
And they just didn't know.
We didn't know to just,
you know,
every crowd isn't ready for comedy.
You have to settle,
people have to be expecting it'll be
settled or it's a fight and I wasn't
prepped to fight at that a moment just
to fight them down.
I did all right,
but that's it.
Sometimes I'll do shows where I have a
rappers or band's opened for me also and
sometimes the crowd at some people in
the crowd into it,
some people aren't,
but it's music that I enjoy so I try to
just mix it up sometimes and have a bit
of a variety show versus just straight
stand up.
Why not?
That's what you want to do.
You definitely do it.
I've,
I've opened for a few bands back in the
day,
but I'll never do it again.
Some of the experiences were just
terrific.
Yeah.
I opened for Bon Jovi once it's theater
in the round.
It was just thing for vh one.
It was in the round and I was on stage
with like a bunch of musical
instruments,
like a lot of like it's like there was a
drum kit there,
how to move around.
I couldn't do anything physical.
There was like a little microphone set
up and then uh,
after I did my set,
I was supposed to bring girls towards
the front of the stage.
They wanted to pick out attractive girls
in the audience,
go back saying no,
no,
around the stage.
So the one they're filming it,
they're the ones who are really close to
the camera,
screaming Bon Jovi and then dirt bag for
backstage.
Right if they turned you and to me into
the wrangler.
But you can also grab some girls.
Here's the deal,
Bro.
Were Road dogs know they,
uh,
they wanted a bunch of because they were
filming it for like vh one,
I think it was at the time,
but I was like,
I can't do keep you on these.
They just don't go well 50 percent of
the time.
Yeah,
it's,
I mean I've done some,
you know,
chance the rapper,
his rapper out of Chicago.
Uh,
I've done some stuff with him and
sometimes he'll go,
well,
and it was one in Chicago and I'm from
Chicago.
So I'm thinking this is going to be
great.
This is my city to dude.
It was just,
it was because I made fun of a,
you know,
Chicago is that live in the city will,
uh,
sometimes you,
you'll meet somebody and you're like,
where are you from?
Chicago.
What part of Chicago was like?
Schaumburg,
Chicago,
suburban.
That's what that Improv is 40 minutes
outside of Chicago.
It's a suburban kind of city,
sort of thousand oaks.
Yeah.
That type of thing.
And so I talked about that.
I did that on stage.
It was just,
it was the venue was in the city and
then I talked about that on stage,
but most of that crowd was like white
kids from the suburbs and then it just
turned from that and they were just
started.
It just got,
got restless and then some dude just
yelled out for no reason.
Just like Kevin Hart.
I was like,
what does that mean?
Wow,
that's hilarious.
Some psychology shit,
right?
He's going to point to the most
successful comic ever compare.
You mean Kevin Hart is,
if he's not the most successful,
he's like top two,
right?
I mean,
who,
what are the arguments?
There's three arguments,
right?
It's like dice clay,
Dane Cook and Kevin Hart and as far as
sustaining it,
yeah,
he's.
His run has been pretty crazy insane and
he has his own shoe,
so I think it's him.
He's kind of motivational shoe,
motivational quotes all over it and
it's.
Shoot.
Actually Kevin Hart's shoot looks better
than a lot of athletes.
Shoes.
Definitely.
He's a smart dude.
He's worked hard,
but that's funny that he thinks that
like yelling that out.
It's going to hurt your feelings.
It was just more weird.
It is weird.
It is weird,
but that's a,
that's a,
that's a jab.
You know,
it's interesting that people do that.
Like you point to like La as if almost
as if someone's success,
even though it's like astronomical,
like crazy success even to a really
successful guy like you.
It will fuck with you.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
I mean you do really well.
I know you're not walking around going
bad.
I wish my life was fucking better right
now.
No,
you're great.
Everything's awesome in your world.
Everything is smooth as fuck.
But someone can yell out.
Kevin Hart
know people,
it's a,
it's a weird space to be in because some
night now you have that to that.
It's a different way.
You got your fans and then you also have
people that just know who you are and
might fuck with you at all.
They just know they like.
And so I,
I went into this Mexican restaurant in
Chicago last week
and uh,
I uh,
I go straight to the bathroom and it is
a great spot in Chicago by the way,
check it out.
Are in
Lincoln and Fullerton and uh,
go to the back
and I come back out as he's tall too
tall black woman and uh,
one of them like I'm right next to us.
She gestures towards me.
Yeah,
he's famous or something like real
dismissive.
I hadn't said anything to her.
I was just being famous or something.
And she says to me,
yeah,
my friends tried to get me to come hang
out with you at mad river bar in
Chicago.
Had tried to get you to come and hang
out,
but we didn't want to.
All right,
why don't you.
But we didn't want to.
Yeah,
some like what are you,
what's happening right now?
Like what are you.
And so I look at her body and she's in
great shape at six to short,
short song.
She got a volleyball books,
so I say,
you play volleyball?
She said,
yeah,
we played at Depaul and so,
uh,
they order their food
down to order my food,
sit down and then I go on my phone and I
google a depaul women's volleyball and
look at a last year and look at the
roster and I look over to her.
I say,
uh,
Hey Ashley,
what the fuck happened last season?
They had a bad season
and in a friend pipes up.
Hey,
we had a lot of good individual
competency assessment,
individual records last year.
And I said,
so you guys had bad teeth?
Chemistry?
But yeah,
it was just,
I felt the need to dig back because I
was just grabbing some fucking tacos and
she just made me feel weird just by
being there.
Well,
she felt like she could get a free shot
at you because you're famous war or she
just does that to people all the time.
Maybe she does.
Maybe she just had a baby.
I was intimidated.
She was tall.
Beautiful girl,
beautiful girl.
We were like a voice.
Maybe a town like mine.
Maybe I couldn't handle my own tone is
actually.
Sounds like you not like me,
but she had kind of not depth but just
suck.
Yeah.
Tone that way.
Maybe she was being rude.
She may have been just a big rude,
giant bitch at once.
Like dude,
to take that challenge.
You know what I mean?
Like if you're a girl that's that big
and athletic,
he could probably fuck up a lot of
dudes.
Yeah.
You know,
that's a big girl.
She probably has to like,
she probably has to test dudes all the
time.
Maybe.
Maybe she was nagging me and I took it
the wrong way.
Yeah.
Maybe if you just took it like an ace,
you just rolled with it.
Like a Shaolin Monk.
Yeah.
Maybe you did neck back,
but the.
But that.
That's actually pretty funny.
So wait,
did I think everything works out great?
I mean,
I know where to find them.
Find it.
I don't know why.
I always want to wonder what someone's
motivation is,
but I always do.
I do too.
You never know.
It's almost like,
why am I bothering?
Why can I just get the fuck away from
this?
Why do I have to find out what someone's
motivation is?
Yeah.
People,
yeah.
I ended up in,
in conversations where I should just
probably leave,
but I'm just curious about what's going
on.
Like who the fuck are you?
Why?
What is your,
what?
What's up with you?
Do that.
Yeah.
And also I have to.
When I have to win.
Well,
it's a game that you're really good at.
Shit talking game.
You get upset when someone starts
talking with you.
I'm like,
wait a minute.
You're a goddamn amateur here.
You should talk about the professional
comedian.
How often have you done this?
How good are you at this?
For Real.
It was fun though.
It is fun.
It's all fun and games to someone's soul
gets crushed.
He doesn't happen in Vegas.
Just a.
It was this girl that I.
no,
not really known that well,
but she's beautiful and she hit me up
out of nowhere.
Hey,
I miss you,
we never messed around and anything,
you know,
and I was just as you,
she missed you.
And so,
uh,
I uh,
I was in Boston at the moment.
I think I'll just in a sort of a,
not a bad move,
a weird mood,
impulsive and she just hit me up out of
nowhere that,
let's go to vegas with a UFC fight,
shit flyer out.
We'd get to the airport around the same
time,
go out,
go to a Calvin Harris has playing,
go there and we get back to the room and
she's Kinda like cold towards me.
Like almost buddy.
I'm like,
Eh,
I mean we never really hung out,
but it's still like flying to Vegas.
It's a,
it's a vibe and it's a little bit of a
subtext to that is vegas also this
associates,
she kind of just go to sleep on me.
I'm like,
we ain't gonna fucking vegas visas.
What the fuck is going on?
What's happening?
You thought you missed?
And so,
uh,
end up,
in the morning,
go for it again.
Like,
she's kind of,
it's like,
I'm like,
does this chick even like,
you know,
it's like I go down on her,
she's completely quiet,
but like moving her body positively,
but not saying a word but not saying a
word to the point where I'm like,
I gotta check and see if this is okay.
I popped my head up.
I'm like,
Hey,
we good
just because I had to do it.
Had to do a consent check.
Marius.
That's a good move though.
Yeah,
Dude.
I had to check.
Man,
are we good?
You good?
She's like,
we're good.
I was back at it,
but she didn't make a noise.
You know,
how weird pussies and sounds with no
moaning or yeps uh,
yes
it would.
Nothing.
No,
no,
it was just,
it was weird.
But I could tell she I've been thinking
about nothing else for
no moaning,
just acapella pussy eating.
But I could feel her body,
like she's moving the body around.
I could,
I could tell she came a couple times
[inaudible] like air came out.
I don't think that's how it works.
I think it is.
I was like,
because at one point yet I feel some air
coming out.
It wasn't a,
but it didn't make a noise.
Um,
I don't think we're ever going to really
know if they're coming or not.
I think it can be a lot of fuckery going
on.
A lot of fake orgasms.
We don't know.
A lot of times girls just fake come so
that you could stop real.
I don't know,
I'm guessing it must've happened,
but I'm just saying I don't think error
coming out constitutes orgasm.
Seems like it should.
Well there should be like a little
Turkey tests or the baby.
She loves me.
Whatever.
We ended up hooking up,
but I go out to lunch and then I
realized we just no,
no computer,
no compatibility.
All this chicken does it.
Even like when you eat her pussy.
So I need to know,
need to know.
It's just lazier.
Doesn't like it,
it all or it's just bad at showing it
does.
It can't even fake.
Just wants to be at the Pfizer.
So we get back to the room.
I'm getting ready.
It's like three ish.
So getting rambling.
I'm gonna.
See the whole thing,
you'll see the prelims and uh,
uh,
so,
but I'm trying to get it in again,
isn't hooked up again.
First Time you have to tell me.
And then she says,
I don't Hook up on the first night.
I'm like,
we already did it already.
What are you talking about?
She's like,
yeah,
that's my role.
I don't do it on.
It's like,
what are you talking about?
She's like,
my,
me and my roommates.
That's our house rule or how's your cock
blocking bitches?
You fucking fly out in the first eight.
What are you talking about?
You already,
we already did it and it's not your
house is it?
And so like what is,
I don't want to know who does that.
That's weird.
And so I Kinda,
I stepped out of the room,
make a phone call.
I talk to my friends to consultant.
What the fuck do I do with this shit?
And
sleeve all your shit in the room and buy
new shit.
That's what you do.
You just know you just,
you,
you have your phone in your hand.
Do you have a computer back in the room?
I didn't.
Okay,
so you go back in,
you don't want to leave the computer,
you go grab your computer,
you go,
I'll be right back.
And then you never come back.
That's what I came back in.
I came back and
came back in a room.
I say I
buy new clothes.
No,
I'm going to take somebody
out in the fight with the computer that
have been great.
I said I would do it.
I say I'm going to take somebody else to
the fight.
Oh Shit.
Uh Oh.
I have my assistant gets you a separate
hotel room and I'll buy you a single
ticket to the fight if you want.
But you know,
I don't feel like you feeling me and
it'd be a disservice to both of us in
wasting each other's time,
but you have another hotel room.
I'll get you a ticket to the.
That's a gentleman's move.
I like,
that's better than what I was gonna do.
I was going to run out the door with a
computer,
but it felt weird to do it and it felt
weird to build up to doing it.
But I had a great night.
Man,
I hung out with another friend in Vegas
and she's much better person.
Beautiful.
Yeah.
It's weird though.
Well that's my fault for that,
but you haven't had a real conversation
with her and I flew this woman out.
That's how beautiful she was.
Why you took a chance life so fast.
You could meet someone like that on the
first night.
They could be the best person you ever
met in your life and you fall in love
forever.
Right,
Jamie?
That's true.
I mean you definitely can.
I support you on both decisions.
Yeah.
I support you on your impulsiveness and
just flying out a beautiful woman and I
support you in continuing to eat her
pussy and asking for consent and the
middle of it.
I support you on that.
Definitely support you.
Getting there another room and doing it
classy and getting her a ticket to the
ticket,
but that's.
Yeah,
even better.
Can I support you 100 percent.
That's a fuck.
You got an a plus or if I was your
teacher,
your professor and how to be a man.
I gave you a fucking a plus.
Thank you.
I'm getting better.
I'm grown up,
successful comedian with resources.
Fly that lady out.
She might be the girl you dreams.
Maybe be able to settle down next time.
Burse settled down.
It's hard trying to grown up.
I bought a building up also real estate.
Bought an apartment building in Chicago.
Oh Shit.
A whole building.
The whole building.
Three unit apartment building.
Do you live in it?
I just bought it.
Don't.
I don't live in his tenants now,
but I want to airbnb.
Wow,
that's interesting man.
What if you started fucking Hannibal
burress hotel?
I was thinking that's what.
That's like a five,
10 year,
five,
maybe 10 years now.
I would have to either get other people
in with funding and stuff,
but I looked at this one place.
It's just one building in Chicago,
but it's a.
it's a lot of money and they will have
to be an all cash buyer and I can't do
it,
so I'm trying to get other people to
partner up.
Man.
The hotel business sounds interesting,
like if you like.
Have you developed a cool because it's
kind of entertaining in a way like
you're in attain those people.
It's not off bro,
my man,
I'm traveling all the time.
I'm in hotels so I kind of know what I
like in a,
in a hotel,
but you know what I mean,
like the experience of going to a hotel
is and a lot of ways like an
entertaining experimentally,
the lounge,
what you have in a lot of stuff in the
rooms,
you know,
in a lot of ways.
Like even the other way like there's a
motel six and catch a Canada,
Alaska that I stayed at and uh,
it's fucking great or hotel sector,
hotel sex.
But uh,
because it's so ridiculous because it's
in this really remote place.
Yeah.
It's,
there's something cool about that.
You know,
there's something cool about just the
standard ness of it all the wood panels
on the door and you know,
like that kind of shit.
I don't even know if they have wood
panels,
but you know what I mean like that.
Like Standard Motel six type look when
you even near a place like that that
like if you went to a place like
Ketchikan Alaska and there was a four
seasons right now with like a,
some sort of a fireplace as broken glass
in it.
Like one of those,
one of those weird ones.
You'd be like,
what the fuck is this?
It wouldn't make any sense,
but the Hannibal burress hotel,
I seen a lot of red velure.
I see a lot like this room.
I see red valora black see gold lace.
I see like a beautiful design to the
place.
I hear good music,
good food.
Smells good.
Food is good.
It's wonderful.
Our food.
Twenty four hour food,
reasonable many bar prices.
I'm like I need to make a profit but I'm
not going to fuck you over.
How many people were talking about in
this hotel?
How big?
Little right?
Like a boatload of one for the first
one,
something like 20 to 30 rooms,
something like that.
That's beautiful.
That's like a fucking party.
20 rooms,
it's like a party,
like if you had like we all have,
we all gathered up all of our friends
that we knew and we all brought
girlfriends or wives and there's 20 of
us.
We could.
We could fill a goddamn 20 room hotel.
Yeah,
easy.
Definitely man,
that's a good move.
Trying to.
I want to do entertainment for fun like
seven years from now and that foot
money.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
Whereas that was not necessary to go on
the road or do a TV show or do a movie
where it's like,
I would really love to do that.
Well then I'm torn because I want your
hotel to be successful,
but I want you to keep doing comedy.
I don't want you to turn into a lazy
pitch.
Not a lazy bitch,
but I would be doing stuff with my real
estate.
I wanna I wanna get my goal.
I want to get another building this year
and him.
You're a magnet and do to get to
multifamily properties a year for the
next five years and then ran for
president and then.
No,
no,
because that only pays 400,000 a year,
but it's the speaking fees.
Speaking feats,
whew.
That's when you make all your money.
You do do your eight years.
Then when you get out,
you make a billion dollars on bomb is
gonna.
Make a.
let me tell you a couple of millions.
You don't know who should be rooting and
crossing his fingers that trump wins as
obama because if,
if trump wins,
Obama will make so much fucking money.
Talking about,
you know,
like democracy and giving speeches about
what it's like to be a president and
what it's like to run the greatest
nation in the world.
Fine.
Either way,
trump always going to be fine either
way,
but he couldn't like it literally
doubled his money.
If trump ones deep.
Here's a theory.
A lot of people have said,
Nah,
I don't think he wants to win.
Do you think he wants to win with the
moves he's been pulling?
I don't know man.
They said he has one office,
one campaign office in Florida that has
four employees.
You had perfect
like Hashtag tiger blood.
He's not.
I mean,
beyond the idiotic shit he said he's not
really running an efficient campaign.
It's entirely possible that he doesn't
really want to win.
If you think about it,
it's entirely possible that he thought
that it would be like,
remember when Howard stern ran for
governor of New York because that
nineties?
Yeah.
Something like that wasn't Jamie.
Um,
I think it was somewhere in there,
but,
um,
I don't think Howard stern really wanted
to be the governor.
Governor,
governor.
Uh,
I just think he wanted to have some fun.
Right.
And that might've been what happened
with Donald Trump.
Like he might've been just thinking he
was going to make a splash.
Have some fun and a nice into deep.
Yeah.
He was still doing his TV show back
then.
Remember,
like he was still the celebrity
apprentice guy or whatever.
It is not a celebrity apprentice.
Is that the name of the show?
Why is it sounds so stupid.
Just the apprentice.
Then it was the apprentice.
So NBC fired him from that show.
Yeah,
because you were saying a bunch of shit
about Mexicans and when they fired him
from the show,
that's when he ramped it up and when he
ramped it up,
that's when he got more and more popular
and that's when he won the Republican
nomination.
Like it's all part of it is because NBC
canceled his fucking show.
That's what happened and this is where
we got to blame.
We got NBC and we got Caitlyn Jenner
because there's a part of America
that when Caitlyn Jenner one the woman
of the year have to being a woman for
six months and when espn did that giant
piece on her and you know,
they're fucking flying over our house
with a helicopter and the drapes are
blowing in the breeze and she's hiding
in the shadows and you're like,
what the fuck?
There's a part of America that was like,
fuck this know.
Got To put our foot down.
We got to put our fucking foot down now.
And then trump came along.
I'm an asshole.
And they were like,
I'm an asshole to stand up,
stand proud people got upset.
I think there's like an ebb and flow to
shit.
I think when things go too left wing,
too progressive to transgenders in the
bathroom,
all that crazy shit when that.
When that goes down,
there's a part of America just not ready
yet and they go foot and that's where
you get trump has ssi.
That solitary solid right
is.
I'm a little fascinated.
When I watched the people in the crowd
just really agreeing,
lift the bullshit.
He said when he said the stuff,
black people,
what are you got to lose?
You add no jobs.
Everybody's in poverty and it's people
in the back like,
yeah,
yeah.
He said a speech.
It's a speech.
Oh,
please fill in.
The black voters just say you don't.
There's no jobs.
You live in poverty.
The schools are bad.
It's 58 percent unemployment with the
youth.
I mean,
what do you got to lose?
It's pretty good impression.
It's not bad.
I know exactly who you're doing.
While we were watching earlier when he
said that Obama founded isis.
We're watching that earlier with like,
this is like a pro wrestling show.
Like he's saying some crazy shit for it,
but he's saying some plates.
We could hear it.
Jamie
trump asking for the vote of every
scene.
African-Americans suffered under
democratic control.
To those I say the following.
Oh my God,
what do you have to lose by trying
something new like trump?
What do you have to lose?
I hope he's high as fuck right now and
he's making a documentary
shadow from the head cover.
It is dumb eyes,
Chris Bells filming all this serious.
Secretly look at them.
They're all screaming,
cheering this black woman back there
again.
What do you look?
Why do you have to lose?
You're living in poverty.
Your schools are no good.
You have no jobs.
Fifty eight percent of your youth is
unemployed.
What the hell do you have to lose?
Wow.
It's amazing to watch the movies.
A coen brothers movie.
Let the end of four years.
I guarantee you that I will get over 95
percent of the African American vote.
I you.
I promise you why?
But even just saying that,
like,
what?
Who gives a shit?
If you're what?
What percentage?
How do you know that?
He doesn't have a plan,
he just talk.
It is.
It's fat,
but the crowd is wet.
Yeah.
If he was doing that for 30 people,
like,
okay,
I get it,
but
I have some pretty significant theories.
I think that people are way too soft.
I think it's way too easy to stay alive
and I think we've never ever had that in
human history and I think that we're
over because of it at a ridiculous rate
and I think there's a bunch of people
out there that have no business fucking
and slash or having kids.
Well,
you just turned very serious.
I'm fucking serious.
And it's not their fault.
It's no one's fault.
It's just the cycle that we're in.
We're in a cycle of safety.
That's what we're in a cycle of
recreational outrage.
People are getting outrage at things
that don't make any sense.
The reason why there's no life
threatening situations that are
constantly at your door.
There's no wolves,
there's no fucking.
Nothing's going wrong.
So we're,
we're going after words.
You can't say retarded anymore,
you know,
don't say tranny.
Don't,
we're getting outraged about shit that
doesn't make any sense.
Product of the Internet is that didn't
survive the war.
Bad example.
Having wolves to come at you.
You're doing.
I think that's just a product of the
Internet.
People being able to react to something
and being able to,
uh,
gather together on something and then
start a petition.
Yeah.
Those are bad examples I have who's
retarded is not a bad example because
it's like,
it doesn't,
that doesn't mean a disease.
It just means someone who's slow to get
things.
We should not a medically imply that
you're picking on someone with a mental
illness.
And in fact,
when people initially had down syndrome,
when the birth certificates would come,
it would call them a mongoloid idiot.
That would be like what it would be
listed on the actual birth certificate.
Mongoloid Mongolo idiot.
Very straightforward.
It's very straightforward and very
bizarre,
harsh,
hard times.
These are hard times,
but we're talking about.
It's good.
It looks.
Everything is good.
It's better to be alive right now is as
good as it gets.
This is a beautiful time,
but we're going to get things like that.
We're going to get things like that
trump thing because it's so fucking easy
to stay alive,
to be alive.
But it's fun.
It's fun for it to be easy to be alive.
Exactly.
I was at my friend's house.
Just kind of bounced back.
Yeah.
He was playing ps four and uh,
he was playing baseball on a ps four,
which I think is horrible.
It wasn't horrible.
Baseball video games.
I'm not in.
So give me football game,
a basketball game.
He fighting,
give me a fighting game,
give me some,
some shooting.
But baseball,
it's not good on a video game that to
me,
obviously it's everybody likes what they
likes,
but I'm over there as a guest.
He doesn't even have a second
controller.
And I,
uh,
so I,
I went on my phone when a postmates
target ps four controller,
the UFC two game.
They brought it was there in 20 minutes.
Twenty of my friend's house.
I don't even,
I don't even have a ps four.
I just wanted to play something
different.
They can do that.
They came through with with the UFC game
under control and we hooked that shit up
and then we went and we were playing
UFC.
How the hell did they do that?
It's because they.
It's just basically a delivery.
You just use the posts.
It's not target.
It's postmates where as a person and
they are driving around in eight waiting
for orders.
Wow.
Yeah,
so I'll take that over and wolves.
Fuck yeah,
no,
I'm not saying that.
I know.
Thinks is the best time to be alive ever
for sure,
but there's guys like you and this guy's
like a lot of my other friends and that
I'm just happy to know and happy to be
around and then there's a bunch of
people out there unfortunately,
and for them they've been exposed to
some bad ideas and they don't have the
best genetics and they're living in
somewhere that sucks and they get to
vote too.
Right.
I do see when I do,
I'll see.
I,
I'm,
I love reading comments on articles just
to just to see is that real?
Is that a real human being that thinks
that that's the date in fascinated all
the time where it hurts me and it makes
me happy.
At the same time,
I can't believe that I live on the same
earth.
Is that type of person that that thinks
that for real or a person that really
thinks that trump will be president.
A person that has these will trump could
use about that.
Right?
I mean it's halfway there.
He's the Republican nominee.
He is.
He's got a super far.
I don't think about that.
I don't think it's going to happen from
here.
The fact that he's gotten his closest
crazy.
It's crazy,
but I think those people that you're
talking about that you can't believe,
they think that way.
They're a product of whatever the fuck
happened to them in their world.
Like there's pockets of the world that
are all a mess right now and if you were
born in that pocket or I was born in
that pocket and the same sort of
circumstances.
That's one of the things that.
It's hard.
It's hard to recognize as a person.
You see someone's an asshole.
He just goes,
fucking asshole,
fuck them,
but in a way we kind of kind of look at
those people go,
damn,
they just got fucked.
They got born into a group of dummies
with a bunch of violent tendencies and
crime and bullshit and nonsense and this
is all they've ever known and they just
trying to get by and you know,
a guy like trump comes in
how long ago
and if it wasn't trump,
it could be a number of motivational
speakers all throughout the country that
might have nefarious intentions.
Yeah.
Anybody who's really like super
charismatic now it's kind of open game.
Like when a guy like trump can come
along and talk as much crazy shit as he
has and in,
in some ways I'm not opposed to him
women because in some ways I'm like,
look,
he has the best guy to fuck this system
in the ass and we know this system
sucks.
It's almost like this guy's a suicide
bomber.
Like trump's like this wild dude with a
vest and a sweaty face and he just run
it into that cafe.
Boom.
Well,
he had a two party system is flawed
anyways.
I'm going to put that on a meme.
It could be more than two vbl able to
run short.
It should be.
She'd be a lot.
Do you know Tom Rhodes?
Yeah.
He was on Duncan trussell's podcast the
other day and he was talking about um,
the way it's set up in Holland.
Taylor seven?
Yeah.
Something.
Jamie see if he could find out how many
candidates they have,
how many parties rather than they have
in Holland,
but it's many,
many,
and they're all like,
they're real reasonable like how they're
placed and there's,
I'm sure there's like a lot of us,
me included that we were upset because
there's some things on one side of that
I agree with some things on another side
I agree with and some things that aren't
being represented at all.
Like the idea that these two people and
whatever opinions they discussed,
the only opinions that we should all be
talking about.
That's crazy.
It's crazy.
Should be more.
Why can't they collaborate on that?
Trump is looking how many they have in
Holland.
This is crazy how many.
They have jamie 11,
but there's 17,
six,
seven.
Didn't vote in the 2012 elections,
so that might be brand new.
I'm not sure if they have 11 different
parties voted in the last year.
They all had candidates.
Wow.
See that's.
That's right.
That's how it should be done.
We were getting hoodwinked by a group of
people that are just controlling this
ancient system and it's not a good
system and they know it's not a good
system,
but the only way you could ever stop
this system is you have to have people
with pure hearts and minds that are
willing to admit the system sucks,
so they're going to lose whatever
position of influence that they have and
step back and be judged by the merit of
their own ideas.
Again,
instead of being a senator or
congressman or a president,
they just say,
look,
this system sucks.
It sucks.
I think it sucks.
Let's get to get the best legal scholars
and and people that understand human
nature and let's can conduct and compose
a system that works and let's really run
the government like it's one of us and
that we're all in this together.
These old folks don't realize that they
just,
they just cling to power until they're
in the grave.
They just hang onto it like it's her
route.
Pancan over the abyss.
They know what they're going to drop
into it.
They don't want to let go,
oh,
well,
you need to control these independence.
Reduced the number of percentages they
have to.
That's just the way it's going to be,
man.
I'm fascinated by that.
Just the level of obviously we have egos
to what to do what we do,
but to one of run a country,
just the level,
dude,
if you can't take jokes,
he can't play basketball and you're not
really good at fighting.
You find a way to be special.
Parts of this are different.
It's a weird impulse,
different type of of pressure.
Here's the weirdest thing about that
impulse.
When you see someone out there in the
world,
when you see someone that you admire,
whether it's an athlete or a brilliant
scholar or whoever the fuck it is,
you see someone,
a musician,
you see some,
you really admire.
That person has accomplished something
amazing,
right?
All the president asked to do is get
people to like them,
right?
That's it.
Like Obama really didn't have a whole
lot of experience in the world,
like creating things or making things.
It went from being a lawyer to a
senator,
right?
Community activists and then state
senator in the Senate.
It mean.
And he got it.
I think.
I don't know if the state senate,
but he got it because uh,
he moved up because the dude had a sex
scandal in Illinois.
Oh,
that's right.
That's right.
And what does that do?
That's your state.
I forget who it was,
but he does not like,
like,
like pick a person,
like a,
you know,
some,
some great person in history that's done
something amazing and you,
you look at them and you're like,
wow,
I would love it if that great person of,
of wisdom and accomplishment if that
person was step up and be president.
Yeah.
It doesn't necessarily have to be the
case in America.
All you have to do is just be liked.
Right?
That's Kinda crazy.
It is.
I don't even know.
I mean both Hillary and trump.
Art Seventy or 65.
Yeah.
They're telling you why are you doing
that?
Right.
Doing it.
People can dream but don't dream so big.
Dude.
You're 30 and you're thinking about
retiring 33.
I'm already buying hotels and picking
them up.
Strategy.
I'm thinking about.
I'm a hundred percent because I like
this.
I like,
I enjoy this,
but I mean I see.
I see how I could go.
I just see how I look at how other
people have handled their moment and how
other people handled their finances and
I don't want to any part of that.
So I'm making every step.
Every thing I do everyday is about,
been super stable seven years from now
and comfortable and to have enough
passive income.
I don't have to worry about that.
That's very smart,
man.
Very smart.
And you're doing it like in a real
proactive way.
Not a whole lot of people look at it
that way.
Everybody else just sort of like rides
it out,
you know,
or it's a weird mindset,
right?
It's like the investment mindset is so
different than the creative mindset.
Yeah.
It's just,
just look,
I mean it's just,
you know,
not just spending smart and just
researched a lot now and just,
you know,
shifting my internet time from the
bullshit.
So just looking at properties and that's
smart to do something else,
man.
And just,
I,
I just don't,
I don't want to end up on those special.
He spent 2014 and the other that not a
real Hollywood story.
I don't want to be on some goofy ass
show that I don't want to be doing eight
years from now where you're like,
oh,
he definitely needed the money.
I don't want to do anything.
Isn't that a funny?
Don't want to say,
man,
that's a funny conversation because we
all know what it's like.
Have you ever been in our bad show
on a badge?
Like a bad TV?
No,
not really.
I haven't done that much.
That many different TVS.
Just a bunch of
dudes out there right now working in
lumberyards,
driving trucks,
taken math,
trying to stay awake,
listening to us right now going,
you fucking bitches are complaining
about being a Shitty TV show.
Where do I sign up,
bro?
Fuck.
Do I sign up?
Get out of this job.
And you're right folks.
You're right.
You gotta you gotta humorous.
You got a humorous because I've been on
a bad show and uh,
I was on a show that was even,
was worse than a bad show.
Good show.
It turned into a bad show.
I was on the show called hardball and it
started out.
These guys who wrote it,
they wrote for the simpsons,
they wrote from married with children,
Jeff Martin and Kevin Curran,
really smart guys and they,
um,
they wrote this hilarious pilot.
We did a,
Jim Brewer was in the pilot and I was in
the pilot and a bunch of other people
that wind up doing,
doing a bunch of different movies and
shit and it was a funny pilot and then
the network got ahold of it and they
just,
Oh fuck the shit out of it.
And they throw in some really hacky
producer who wound up getting he will.
He wound up getting fired like halfway
through the six episodes that we did and
it was allegedly,
there was a bunch of other shit going on
and the writing was off the charts bad.
It was.
So I got to be like on a bad show,
but it's a terrible feeling for season.
Next six episodes six.
That was the first.
The first one was the pilot,
which was really funny.
And then it just was like,
all of a sudden it was over here doing
something that was terrible and you're
better off doing nothing than doing
something you hate.
Yeah.
That doesn't make any sense because you
make money and ultimately it's worth
doing.
And ultimately for me it was definitely
worth something because I learned from
the experience.
You can't just do a TV show.
You got to be sure.
And even if you're sure,
like the pilot was really funny.
I was pretty sure that that would be
okay.
It doesn't matter because a bunch of
other factors can fall into place.
Yeah.
I just remembered I did do a bad show.
Is My TV show last shit?
What happened with that?
It uh,
I think it mean we had our moments,
but it just,
it might need some more booze to get the
truth out of here with some ice.
It's just,
it had his moments,
but we didn't,
we,
they came with the idea that came to me
and the producing comedy central.
It basically,
this is the show,
this idea.
Adam will do a sketches man on the
street stuff.
Just just figuring out the quest answers
to these questions,
but it's just,
I guess we didn't really focus it in
focus,
the,
uh,
the point of view and it was kind of all
over the place and we had our funny
moments and did some,
a couple of good sketches,
but it just,
by the end of it,
it didn't feel I wasn't excited anymore
those last two episodes where just,
you know,
and we do it in front of a live
audience.
It really was just about finishing that
shit man,
that man.
But I,
I'm happy I did it and that I had that
moment where,
you know,
for what,
what was that two months last year at my
own TV show.
Not a lot of people get to say that.
Uh,
but,
uh,
yeah,
it's just,
you know,
you learned a lot.
I learned a lot.
It was fun.
Got To work with some cool people.
But yeah,
it just wasn't as far as what I wanted
my first,
uh,
you know,
kind of headline and project to be a.
It wasn't that beautiful.
Jamison
and whiskey and nice just brought up,
um,
now what,
what were you trying to do and what went
wrong?
You know,
what my interviewer now give me,
give me some ice.
I sounded like Matt Lauer was like I do.
I just went into interview mode as I got
some ice.
I think I kind of went into it not,
you know,
not really knowing.
I mean I learned later on how to run
things better and how to give people
direction on what I needed a little bit
better,
but I don't think we came in with a
focus because I was thinking with a TV
show that not that we would completely
winging it,
but that we would,
uh,
be able to kind of find it as we go.
We never did a true pilot episode.
Cheers.
Cit.
We never did a true pilot episode.
I pilot episode was our premier episode
and I look at some of my choices.
I chose this weird ass closing bit on
there.
Well,
Oh,
why did I pick that as a bit?
I didn't write it,
but I liked it.
Sometimes you'd like stuff in the
writer's room that is hilarious,
and then you execute that shit.
And what were we doing?
Can I ask you a question?
Sure.
Okay.
Outside of a television show,
if you were just sitting around and
someone said,
Hannibal,
I want you to just be your creative
self.
Would you ever gravitate towards writing
sketches?
What I gravitate towards,
right.
And Yeah,
just on your own.
Oh my own.
No,
but it was sometimes where I come up
with something that definitely works
better visually than,
uh,
than Stan does stand up.
Oh,
I try to tell a standup bit like,
but it will work better,
uh,
visually animated or as a sketch yet.
Yeah,
definitely.
I agree.
There's,
there's,
there's some subjects that I've had an
abandoned because they really did.
I thought they were hilarious,
but I couldn't.
They just didn't,
weren't there were a better idea for a
play than they would be for a standup
comedy?
Yeah.
But when we're coming up,
everybody wanted to be on Saturday night
live because Eddie Murphy was on there.
Everybody wanted to be on sketch comedy
shows because that would lead to these
big careers like Adam Sandler and Rob
Schneider and all these people that we
became like these huge movie stars,
right?
So we all like gravitate towards acting
and then there was sitcoms where Rosanne
made all this money and then Seinfeld
made all this money.
He's like,
Oh shit,
I gotta get to.
Yeah.
But when I was on that bad sitcom
halfway and I was like,
this is not what I wanted to do.
Right?
I fucked up.
I listened to the I want to do stand up.
If it does what I want to do now with a
guy like you,
like what I want to hear as you talk
about everything I don't want to hear.
I mean I want to hear you doing prepared
shit.
If that's what you want to do.
Like what I would want to hear from you.
If I was a producer and I was a network
and I was comedy central,
I would say handle,
listen,
fuck.
All these executives.
Fuck all these producers.
What do you think is funny?
What do you want to do?
I want to know.
I don't want a bunch of people filtering
the Hannibal Vision by the time,
like when Doug,
Stan hope and I did the man show,
which was a giant mistake.
One of the big problems with was with
that show was like with Doug and I had a
fucked up idea by the time it would get
to.
It would be all watered down by the time
we'd ever get to the television.
There's no way you could just have the
only way to do that.
It's like the Internet.
The Internet is the only way where you
could just like if someone was smart,
they would come along and they would
say,
listen,
if I was comedy central,
I would say animal.
It's just like a bunch of money and
we're just going to give you a
production team and just come up with
whatever the fuck you want to come up
with.
I want you to take six months.
Just think about what you want to do is.
I know it's going to be funny.
I think you're hilarious.
I'll take six months,
come up with whatever the fuck you want
to do,
let's put this shit online,
do this,
come on mobile.
And then if they wanted to make a
television show out of that,
I mean that's what happened with Arisa
fear show.
Yeah.
It will do it as the online thing.
And the honestly the online's better.
It's better to get on the online.
No,
it's going to online.
It's there always.
Is there any minute of any day.
If it's just the TV version of it.
I mean once it goes online then it
becomes equal to the online version,
but there's no like loss and not having
the TV version because like if someone
watches comedy central during the show,
when Ariz on like what is always
ratings,
what did he get?
Like a million dollars an episode or a
million people in episode?
A million dollars an episode.
He'd be very happy.
It's crazy.
But if he got a million people an
episode,
like you could easily,
if you had a crazy viral video like some
of Joey Diaz videos,
they probably have close to a million.
Right?
How many Joey's um,
things on a,
this is not happening.
Have more than a million.
Find out what Joey Diaz his stories on
this is not happening
now.
I guarantee you they have a million
people.
I mean it's just people don't watch it
on their phone.
They could watch whatever they tell your
friends.
Yeah.
So if you did that and you had a show
like that,
it was just you.
If you,
if you really want to do a show,
just you doing whatever the fuck you
think is funny.
Shit.
I'd watch them and figure it out.
A dvr the shit out of that show.
I'm going to figure it out.
I've been kind of.
What do we got here?
That's us.
What is this?
This is not happening.
Joey Diaz.
One million.
One hundred 29,000.
Four hundred 87 views.
That's what I'm talking about.
Yeah.
I mean that's like,
that's real numbers man.
I mean that's the same kind of numbers
you get if you have a TV show.
It's the same shit,
right?
Definitely.
It's real close,
man.
We're like maybe a year or two away from
the idea of being on a television show
being no different than the idea of
being on a youtube show or even,
I mean,
a lot of these,
I'm doing some celebrities react a shell
on Thursday where they,
like,
our viewership is four times the average
TV show,
like the,
in the,
in the email,
they,
they talk about their numbers like this
two times and knowing what is four times
that is,
isn't it,
didn't have a crazy subscriber list,
uh,
in all on youtube,
millions of subscribers.
Youtube is where it's at for a lot of
things.
It's just a matter of we just A.
I mean,
that's how comedy central now judges the
success of that shows not just on the,
on,
on air,
the initial area,
it judge it based on the facebook
shares,
the youtube stuff,
the snapchat thing and all that's to
come.
It's a combined a formula they use to
judge the successful show.
It's smart.
I mean,
that's really the way to think about it
because they have to be honest.
This is a giant percentage of the people
that are gonna Watch her show on youtube
or any other weather.
I mean,
I don't know how many people watch
comedy central Dot Com.
Do you know?
I would imagine it's not nearly as much
as youtube,
but what's amazing about youtube is
there's only one youtube.
Yeah,
like how is there not a million youtube?
How is it not a million of these weird
websites where you can just upload video
anytime you want and watch the craziest
shit all day long.
I mean there's live leak,
right?
There's a.
What are the,
what are the other ones?
A lot of weird ones that are,
that are based on.
They're not popular.
Not why.
Yeah.
Well because one popular one.
If you say Google bought Youtube though,
skynet
hundred and $35.
Million Bucks is all that tape too.
That's it for Youtube.
Yeah.
That's good.
When did they buy?
2,000.
Four or five.
I think.
How much does Kanye is entire
sneaker line worth?
If he sold every sneaker,
is that 100 million worth of pretty
close to that problem?
That's probably pretty close.
Yeah.
That's amazing.
That's how much they paid for that.
For Youtube.
Youtube is a monster.
Yeah.
It's somehow or another in this world of
the Internet where there's probably like
what?
How many hundreds of millions of
websites?
I take that back side or correct that
one point six,
5 billion in stock now,
the owner's son of a bitch,
Jesus Chamie.
Meanwhile,
here's some perspective.
The UFC sold for 4 billion.
It's more valuable to kick people in.
The deq and the head an elbow in the
face than it is to create youtube.
Yeah,
I looked something up on it the other
day.
I think that's why there's numbers were
stuck in my head.
It's a,
at least from what I read at cost,
something like six point $7,000,000,000
to run youtube right now every year,
year.
And like the revenue they're getting my
baby just from ads.
It's like less than 5 billion.
So they're taking a loss on it.
But why is,
that's just for doing the future bet.
Kinda like it won't be that for four or
five more years.
It's just how it happened.
Oh,
so that's why there's only one youtube.
It's fucking tough,
but
that makes sense.
It's amazing though.
I mean that's a.
If you want to talk about an incredible
example of success,
like youtube is the only video upstream
place that everybody or upload place
that everybody recognizes instantly in
the sea of the Internet is a,
that's incredible.
As top management.
They do do some shit.
You do.
Do you do ads with them?
No,
no,
I mean they put up ads but I don't have
anything to do with it.
Um,
we do just adds on this show and then we
upload the,
the difference between the Youtube
version of this show and the podcast
version.
The podcast version has,
um,
has,
uh,
adds that we read,
you know,
like from,
um,
a promo,
a email thing,
and then the youtube one has no ads.
It just goes up.
And then whatever ads,
youtube ads and ads for.
I took someone with a on it Zealand,
I think I'm feeling,
I don't know,
maybe the,
the whiskey is cancelling it out,
but maybe I'm just normal now.
I'm feeling a little drunk.
I'm good.
Yeah,
I'm just not going to help the drunk too
much.
Maybe it'll help you formulate
sentences.
Meanwhile,
the word formulate came out.
Very clumsy.
Formulate.
You ever been to Israel?
No.
Have you know?
Hmm.
I got offered a Gig and Israel don't go
in June.
Reactionary.
I don't know.
You should go to.
Sure you took it.
I took the Gig.
Um,
when is it for?
It was supposed to be in Gillette.
Supposed to be spoiler alert
on earth lead,
but still an interesting story.
I so took this gig in Israel in Tel Aviv
only because my ex girlfriend is Israeli
is Israeli.
And so I'm thinking,
fuck,
you have a machine gun in your mouth?
No,
she's
Israeli.
I'm thinking,
Hey,
maybe she wants to come on this trip
with me.
You know what I mean?
I'll take this,
I'll take this and a well.
And then I took the Gig,
turns out she was mad because he was
like,
you didn't go to Tel Aviv with me when
we were together.
So now I got this Gig in Tel Aviv,
this not even routed with anything else.
And then I started getting these tweets
when people,
why are you going to Tel Aviv?
Do you know what they're doing to the
Palestinian people supporting genocide?
I'm like,
I was just trying to get back on my ex
girlfriend.
Be like,
you are supporting hate.
You put the support and the Zionist.
I'm like,
I didn't know.
I just heard he was dope beaches.
I was getting all these.
And they like,
why?
Why would you do this?
Join these other artists that are
boycotting Israel.
Is that common a boy?
I think it was like I live.
I think it was,
it was a bunch of other people that
won't tour vanilla ice,
vanilla ice.
Uh,
Craig Zappa.
Craig Mac.
Yeah,
correct.
Mac.
Ellen Degeneres,
a g depth.
A Little Wayne and lot of people bet
midler won't go over there.
Oh my God.
But yeah.
So it was just fun and getting all of
these angry political tweets.
Okay.
That is fucked up.
What's going on over there?
But that's not.
Can I be sympathetic and also maybe do
this gig.
I ended up canceling Gig,
but now because of the tweets and the
anger was just because I booked a movie
that completely with it,
the movie was more important than in the
motherland.
But let me ask you this.
Honestly.
If the girl was going to go with you,
he knew you're going to get your freak
on.
Would you have taken the Gig over the
movie?
Have you?
Would you have broken her heart and not
taking her back to the motherland?
I wouldn't send the back another time.
Another time.
Move a gentlemen.
See not.
It's over bitch.
Sorry you missed it.
I'm on fast and furious.
Fifty 6,000 girl.
I'll be so pissed for a dude.
Broke my crazy trip to Israel for fast
and the furious 56 to do three,
three lines in it.
Fuck you.
And Fuck.
Vin Diesel.
Fuck you.
Get run over by a charger
and
that's a good move though.
Take her another time.
But did you guys communicate afterwards?
Did you settle down to the issue that
you never took her to go
to Israel?
Why you guys settled?
I don't think that is some issues you a
you can't settle down and you just work
on what you can work on.
Again,
let me bring this up.
Recreational outrage and let me pose a
scenario.
Okay.
Here's the scenario.
You two are living in a cave.
Okay.
And a bear to say her sister and you
guys saw it and he escaped and you,
you,
you fought off the bear's friends with a
spear and you made the best friends.
Other than 500,000 years ago,
handle a $500.
Where the other barriers,
other barriers instead of friends?
I'm making it up as I go a little bit.
Made it sound like when you said the vas
for hasn't made it sound like it could
be like a direct where the animals,
that's it.
Good.
This other big.
Don't think bears a friend was anything
they can eat,
but I just assume it's parents,
friends,
just other bears.
It's another.
I'm so sorry.
You make a really good point.
So you're managing to save this girl
from being predated upon by these
monsters.
Just giant monsters.
You fight them off and you get her up to
a top case carrier over your shoulders.
You lay her down on the landscape.
Yes,
unscathed,
but her sisters debt.
Yeah,
and you,
you,
you lay her down on the skins of a bear
that you have also killed yourself with
a fucking spirit.
Had a separate system with a separate
situation.
This is all clean every day.
Yeah.
She's not going to complain about you
not taking her to the motherland,
to Israel when you guys were dating.
She's not going to give a fuck because
the stakes are much higher.
This is you,
your hero.
You've saved her physical entity.
You've said to her soul,
from passing on to the next generation
of doubt,
this beyond land where no one knows what
the fuck is really going on and you get
glimpses.
If you take mushrooms,
you stick your head and you pop it back
and you never really quite sure whether
or not whether you saw whatever you saw
was real.
Then you would fuck her on that fucking
rug.
But meanwhile,
yeah,
you would.
You'd fucker.
You'd be happy.
She'd be happy for saving her life and
maybe not her sister.
How about a cousin?
Her cousin who was kind of Cunty,
her cousin who was fat and big shed
giant ankles,
and she hated her whole life because she
had shitty genetics.
She got pink hair.
She likes to bully small boys.
How about that girl?
Maybe you'd have to ask her.
Can imagine if that was the case in the.
In the cave people community.
There was this one girl was like cock
blocker.
She had rules.
She's like,
I can't fuck you because my friends tell
we all have a role when we go back to a
room.
We just,
we just can't do it.
I can't fuck a guy on the first date,
first date,
only after he's built at least seven
fires for,
you know,
so sad.
So sad.
People not being able to be themselves
because they met so many people along
the
way that weren't themselves.
And they're like,
God damn it.
I can't show you yet.
Yeah.
I can't take off my Kabuki mask and show
you the soul.
Eternal self.
Yeah,
I do.
Sometimes I,
uh,
this,
it was this waitress at the,
uh,
at,
at the Darra smoke a joint.
His restaurant is a good store,
I can tell.
And,
and she was,
uh,
she was beautiful when I was hanging out
with my friend in vegas that she's cool
with,
you know,
I can openly talk about other women with
her while she was like,
yes,
she's beautiful.
She's and this waitress,
she was so aka lesbian,
I don't know if that's the word,
but this wages was so beautiful.
You ever meet a waitress way?
She'd be playing like the superfly sound
dry.
Do you haven't meet a wages where you
shouldn't be a waitress?
It was,
she,
it wasn't about her looks.
She just had a sort of composure to,
uh,
just kinda restrained.
She was beautiful,
but still,
she doesn't know yet that people will
look at you weird if you're a waitress.
That's what it is.
She's a young person who doesn't
understand and if she's lucky,
she meets a guy like Hannibal burress
who doesn't judge her for the fact that
she,
when she brought me in a bill,
I wanted to say,
I want to say,
what are your dreams and how can I help
with them?
Wow.
Did you say?
No?
I didn't say why you didn't say it
because we don't hang out enough.
But if I was right next to you and be
like,
dude,
it was the same time.
Let this shit go.
Fuck it.
Who gives a fuck?
Do you miss her?
I uh,
I don't miss it.
No,
but I know where she is.
I know she's in.
She's in Vegas.
How long ago was this?
This was a,
this was yesterday.
You should go back to Vegas.
Are done.
Fly back.
But you know why I didn't.
Uh,
she,
she knew who I was and you know,
I was at.
I didn't want her having to sit with my
weird energy for the rest.
She had to work her shift after my
weird,
intense energy on it.
So I didn't want to leave that stink on
it for the rest of the day.
Oh.
So that might be me overestimating my
effect on people,
but you know what I mean,
that's very honest with you because she
don't need that.
That's really honest.
Again,
Kudos.
Eight plus eight plus for handling that
weirdness.
Yeah.
What do you do?
I mean maybe she wasn't in you at all.
Just thought were really funny
most of the time.
A lot of the time.
A lot of time.
When was the fans they own nothing else
besides that.
And that's fine too.
I get,
I get sometimes girls happened to dm on
instagram and it'll say,
hey,
you wanna
meet up and have a drink and I'll just,
uh,
sometimes depending on my mood,
I said you try to get the pipe just to,
just to see what the tone is
because that's what a,
that's a reference to a Jr Smith for
basketball player.
Like some girl posted up,
a
girl posted up his dog.
So I'll say that sometimes
man amongst men.
How about him for president?
Run,
run.
But I'll just say that sometimes because
also I don't want.
It's funny.
I think that's right.
I think is whack for a girl just coming
my dm.
Yeah,
that's A.
Oh my God.
That's brilliant.
So I stole that.
Familiar with what you're trying to get
the pipe.
Holy Shit.
And that girl blew him up tonight.
Dope Smiley face.
I'm a Whoa,
look.
How weird is it?
You could see him,
but her face is blurred out.
Yeah.
We should all be able to see both
parties.
If you want to put this up,
you can't hide the darkness.
We should be able to know who you are
too.
That's a weird thing to do.
But uh,
yeah.
So.
So I'd like to set the tone sometimes
just to see,
because I like that word too.
[inaudible] girls hit me regular style
and just say,
Hey,
you want to grab drinks?
What?
You just hit me up the same way you talk
to your friend.
Hey,
you want to grab drinks?
Oh their shoes.
Say something better to me.
I'm a famous comedian.
Say something clever.
Send a pic or your pussy some cities or
some Jesus.
Don't just say you want to grab drinks
like this is a.
This is not a.
This is not a normal situation.
If it was normal,
you wouldn't be hitting me like this.
So say something better.
I see your point,
but they don't want to.
Let's think about their point.
Their point.
I know what that point is.
They want to play a casual.
They want to play it cool.
They want to keep some innuendo and keep
it subtle and I get that and sometimes I
play along with that Shit Shit to say.
Sure.
Let's grab a drink,
grab a drink and I'll go through with it
and then when everything goes down I
wanted to go down but sometimes I just
want to hear you say it.
I want to see you say it right?
Yeah,
I hear what you're saying.
You're saying that you have sexual
attraction to them and you want to be
sure if this shit goes any further,
that this isn't just some weird
celebrity thing which ends up being
something because sometimes they be
like,
no,
I don't want to.
Fuck.
I just want to hang out with one of the
funniest guys around.
Well,
you know what?
I'm only in this town for a night.
I don't want to have drinks with a fan.
Just casual platonic as drinks.
I think you should value my time warner
or here's the other Po.
The other possible point of view,
they don't understand why they're even
attracted to you.
They just know they are.
Yeah,
they know the funny going on.
They know that the,
the.
You're hilarious.
They know
that you're smart as fuck.
They're drawn to you.
They're confused.
They can't believe they're in contact
with a celebrity.
Not necessarily.
I have to accept the DMV.
I know,
but they're in contact with.
You
see a lot of times and I.
it's something that I've accepted that
sometimes they just want to,
they want to hang out for the fucking
Brac.
This one chick
yo at in Athens,
Georgia.
I use,
I use dating apps sometimes and I use
bumble,
bumble.
What is your profile so we can get your
lead?
It's just A.
I deleted it actually recently.
Oh girls.
Because I was like,
I deleted it because I was like,
ah,
this is too much.
There's too much going on.
So this chicken,
Athens,
Georgia,
Georgia has come through the room.
I think that's where forrest Griffin's
from.
She come to the room about.
I'd never met her.
I uh,
she come through hotel like four.
We go over to the hotel bar,
grab a beer,
come right to the room.
It's kind of stiff and awkward,
but she's kind of there for and uh,
ended up having,
we have sex and uh,
it was pretty quick.
She's about to leave the room and I see
you later.
I got a towel around my waist.
She's like,
Eh,
can we take a picture real quick?
Like,
no,
they get no fucking post sex.
Seth posts,
groupie sex selfie.
What are you,
what world do you live in?
Just fucking take this story with you
and get Outta here.
I'm not getting a Selfie,
but I make bad decisions all the time.
I feel like we should have a commercial
break.
I don't know how to deal one yet.
We can't splice in commercials.
You know?
I think,
uh,
it's hard being a Groupie,
just like it's hard being handled burse
it's,
it,
it's hard.
It's hard being a person in person.
Navigating these waters is weird waters
for,
for everybody.
And I can,
I get the energy is bad.
Something that bad,
but just as a,
you know,
what's weird thing,
here's what's weird.
People don't even know why they're
attracted to certain people.
Didn't understand it,
you know,
and they try to quantify it.
I think,
uh,
you know,
there's some people that are attracted
to people in weird ways and then they
almost want to test the waters.
I want to meet you,
Hannibal.
I don't think it's even.
I don't think it's attractive.
I think it's,
I think it's a straight up.
Sometimes it's attracted and then
sometimes it's just straight up your
personal television.
Your personal stage could be that you
have to the,
but there are a lot of them were like
really young,
you know,
if a person's 24 years old,
how much do they really understand
completely about their motivations.
Right.
You know,
or when someone's 22 w,
w you're doing,
a lot of times it's like on instinct
and then you're sort of self correcting
as you go along,
you know?
Yeah.
Does that make any sense?
You just do.
I mean made still occasionally make
decisions.
Whatever.
What the.
Yeah,
of course.
Why did I let that person in my
apartment?
You drink.
I should've gotten a hotel room.
It's the drinking drank and God dammit,
we're drunk right now.
I'm going to say I'm drunk at buzz buzz.
These are big gas drinks I poured and
this is really not smart.
Put this on the Internet about to.
We're about to give them beamed up,
man
up and clipped up.
Clip it up.
We can handle this together.
They going to say we're going to be
pilot and copilot massaging this
comedian,
Hannibal burress
dude,
your unfiltered and everybody wants to
be unfiltered,
but nobody wants unfiltered.
Yeah.
Nobody wants unfiltered,
but there's a lot of people that don't
want unfiltered and they want you to
think that nobody wants unfilter yeah.
Like you're not saying anything that I
wouldn't expect you to say.
If we were alone and the microphones
were off of you and I were hanging out
at the comedy store,
we'd have the same conversation.
I'd be laughed at the exact same way.
Actually we would because it be a bunch
of other comedians,
ear hustling and I went into just them.
But you'll tell it online.
Oh,
what it is.
It's not.
I'm more like this doesn't.
It does seem.
It seems even though obviously it's way
more people listening and watching,
but it's more about the visual of other
people.
Like you know,
you having a conversation with somebody
and then you feel other people.
That's not part of the conversation
where that feels more unnatural to me
than doing this.
You know what I'm saying?
I agree a thousand percent.
Yeah,
and it probably doesn't make any sense.
It doesn't make sense.
It doesn't make any sense at all.
It.
That's why it's like
I think like it's not their fault if
someone's hanging around us.
There's been situations like that before
where someone is like weaseled into a
conversation between me or you or me.
It was me and des and some other dude
the other night and this guy came up to
us and just sandwiches way into a
conversation in the kitchen.
I'm like,
how'd you get back here?
Come on man.
Like,
but part of me,
part of me thinks like if I was that
guy,
how would I do it?
What do you do if you walk up,
you know,
you,
you were at the comedy store,
you're supposed to go left to take a
leak and you go right and you're into
the kitchen and Joey Diaz is talking to
Ari Shaffir and Hannibal and you guys
were all hanging out and hilarious
fucking stories are being told and you
just want to stand there and stare.
Yeah.
You want to.
I mean you listen to it.
I would do it right now.
I'll do it right now if those guys hated
me for some reason,
those guys wouldn't be my friends
anymore.
I'm like,
I don't know what the fuck I did,
but
damn,
I got to find a hole in this vent so I
could listen in on and talk
two and a lot of weight is interacts as
I had lit a fad,
which I have a lot because I go out a
lot and go drinking and so I'm super
exposed to all the time.
Uh,
but I was in Chattanooga last year.
We played this venue and we go out
afterwards.
Me,
my sugar,
Al Jackson,
I'm a boy.
Marcus,
a couple of girls we met and we go to
this bar,
nice bar.
Not that many people that maybe 12,
15 people in the whole bar this big as
pool tables over on this side.
Bars here.
They had these wings.
They,
these smoked wings that I was eating
maybe the best ways I've had top five,
like I'm crushing them.
It was a spiritual experience.
What's so good about them?
They just well made.
They were grilled.
They were cooked well,
I wish I remember the name was,
but it was,
the wings were so good ground.
I'm just killing these wing,
marinated in the zone.
Maybe marinated,
had good sauce.
Hot.
You like spicy?
I like spicy.
I don't remember if he,
but I'm destroying these winnings and
I'm in the zone.
Like it's,
it's like,
um,
I think it was NBA
exam.
I was on fire and then this dude comes
up,
man.
Hey,
I was at the show.
Uh,
can I take a picture with you?
I'm saying yeah man.
Just A.
I'm eating wings right.
I'm eating right now.
Let's just give me a few minutes.
I'm happy to take a picture.
He's like,
come on man,
let me take a picture.
I was just telling me,
man,
I'm eating right now.
Let me,
let me just finish eating.
And he said,
would you rather me take a wing or take
a picture?
And I said,
I'd rather you get the fuck out of my
face.
Right.
I told you because he pushed.
He was,
it wasn't a crowded bar.
It wasn't like a meet and greet.
I told him I was happy to take a picture
with them afterwards.
Just let me finish my.
I had sauce all over my hands and shit.
It's like they'll give it a few
reasonable.
Give me a few minutes.
He asked.
Cool.
He asked cooler and I'm reasonable about
it and shit,
but you know a little bit.
I know he's doing a bunch about it,
so on the other side of the bar,
it's another bigger space with the where
the bathroom is.
So I go to the bathroom and I step out
coincidentally who's at the bathroom.
I walked.
He don't say nothing.
I walked past them and then it's a.
it's a long space is before you get to
the interest of the bar again and I get
there.
He's standing by the bathroom door.
He yells,
thought you were cool.
Hannibal thought you were cool.
You act like an asshole.
I paid $25 for your show.
You you're acting like you're Dave
Chappelle or some shit.
And
Hellen Kevin Hart and how many days span
between stories far apart from each
other,
but it's a goat to where people want to
try.
You try to bring up,
right?
Yeah.
You
take your Dave pick up those stories.
Me motherfucker.
Right?
Basically he said,
hey,
if Dave Chappelle was mean to me when I
had kept bothering him while he was
eating,
I'd get it,
but you,
you have to give me your day day span.
I was like,
fuck you.
You paid for a show.
You didn't pay for fucking meet and
greet.
I told you I take the fucking picture
with you after I was done eating.
Then you kept pressing me and so he
bitched about the $25 or whatever.
Now I'm like sitting and stewing,
man about.
I'm at the bottom.
This motherfucker.
I told him I'd take a picture with this
barn even crowded.
It would have been easier to take a
picture with her if he just fucking
relax and then I can take $25 out of my
pocket.
I balled it up.
He's over at the pool table.
I woke up and I throw it out,
take your money back if that's what you
wanted,
and then he picked.
He throws it back everything.
I balled it up,
hit him in the face with it.
Oh my goodness.
And then they were ready to fight and I
was ready to fight the dude,
but then his brother was there and while
this was all going on,
I'd be like,
where's the exit?
Who's wearing clothes where I can't tell
if they have a gun.
And then his friends going on that is
fred.
I was ready to punch dude acts and then
his friend pulled out a camera phone
like,
oh,
your publisher is gonna love this.
And I'm like,
I guess we're not fighting it by you're
ready to fight.
Come on.
Twenty five bucks.
It wasn't about the 25 bucks.
It was about,
about the words about to just talk and
shit and just acting like I wasn't.
I was being totally chill in and saying,
Hey,
I will let me finish.
Let me finish eating.
Fucking wipe my hands.
I'm happy to take a picture with you.
And he kept pressing me and then he
popped off afterwards.
After that.
I thought we settled it.
Yeah,
I know what you mean,
man.
I'm from someone who's been interrupted
while you're eating.
It is annoying,
but I've always tried to try to figure
out like,
Whoa,
okay,
what is,
what's the difference between how weird
it is for me
eating for off to me that is better at
that too.
Over time where I put myself,
it's weird in a spot and I,
and I'm nice and I remember and I
remember what it is to them for them to,
to ask for that.
Yeah.
Listen man,
I got a man crush on Anthony Bourdain
that every time I hang around with them
I feel goofy.
It's just a fact.
I just like,
like I think I liked the way he thinks.
I like his balls.
Guy Takes up Jujitsu when he's 58 years
old,
you know?
And uh,
like I think in certain situations you
have to understand that like the way you
feel around someone is affected by your
respect for them.
And sometimes it gets weird,
right?
Like if a dude comes up to you,
it's like,
hey,
Hannibal Fan,
I've got a picture and you're like,
I'm eating right now,
man,
relax.
And that they don't even know what the
fuck they're saying.
You know,
like if,
if I'm a Hannibal Fan and I walk up and
you got a mouthful wings and was just
this real quick,
we'll just take this picture.
I've got the fuck out of here.
I can't believe I took this chance.
But I was like,
I told them,
yeah,
I mean,
but I get that side of it and that's why
I wish I didn't react like that and I
wish I,
I kept a chill and what I do more often
now.
But.
So it's just,
I don't know what you just said is
beautiful.
I do more often now.
So you're thinking about it.
I'm aware of it
need me to come up to me and just,
uh,
and I just remember what it is that,
that and that it is a,
uh,
a privilege that they,
you know,
support my work and,
and try to just give them that moment
versus.
But even still,
some mother fuckers I genuinely root and
sometimes people can be entitled and
sometimes people don't care if you're
talking to three women,
right?
They will,
they will bust that shit up.
You're right.
I mean,
it's one of the things about life.
You never know who you're going to run
into.
You run into someone that's just goofy.
Yeah.
But it's,
it's,
uh,
it's interesting.
It's just an interest in Lens,
man.
It's a,
it's an interesting Lens,
not just for you,
but also for me to look through what
you're talking about.
But for other people too as well.
You know,
I think,
uh,
we're,
we're all doing this weird thing,
man.
We're all just surviving in this strange
life that's temporary.
If we're lucky,
we get a hundred years if you're lucky.
But the last super,
that's super dope for lucky,
for the last few years he was just hang.
Yeah,
just hanging on and just waiting to get
weary enough.
So you let go and slip into the abyss.
Yeah.
I try to keep the perspective,
especially in this business willing,
this is a.
maybe this is a limited moment.
This is a limited time.
That's good.
It's not a hate when people like you say
that.
That's.
I think I was talking about this last
time.
It's funny as fuck,
dude,
you're not going anywhere.
I hate when someone who's fucking pisses
me off.
Jim Norton,
if you listen to me,
you can stop telling me.
Stop.
Stop telling me you're worried about
the.
Stop it.
You're fucking awesome.
I hate when people don't know.
They're awesome.
You know,
relaxed bitch.
But even Jim Norton,
you're fucking amazing.
Hilarious.
You have to.
You don't have a goddamn thing to worry
about.
It's going to be people going to see Jim
Norton for the end of time and I'm one
of them.
I feel the same way about you.
I mean,
I just,
I think a seven years,
seven more years,
hotels got hotels on the
stocks,
you know,
you do stocks up a little bit.
I do a really intelligent Jewish
gentlemen who handle your money,
so because you're too fucking do it.
That's what I do.
I,
uh,
I a big fan of the Jews.
They had put some,
those people,
the money people,
they have put a lot of my money in
mutual funds.
Then I looked at what a mutual fund is
with other people buying stocks,
but I don't,
I don't like that.
And a cash album,
mutual funds and I want to pick my own
stocks.
Well,
if you're really into owning hotels of
picking stocks,
I understand me.
I'm not into that,
you know,
a company I like.
Is this company called Catapult Sports?
They do,
they do wearable gps technology who I'm
the Golden State Warriors is using some
other proteins using like,
what are you wearing?
Like a steak for practice in different
training.
They tracked athletes' performance.
Wow.
How crazy is that?
The tracking people from a satellite,
how fast they're moving.
Just different.
I mean,
I can't get into the super specifics of
it.
A Mark Cuban invested in,
um,
2014.
I,
uh,
I found them on accident when I was
looking up.
I was looking up some pharmaceutical
company called catalyst and not for some
reason my brain put catapult.
Then I found this company started
looking it up.
I found them by accident.
I found them on accident,
started looking it up and I uh,
I invested in of heavily.
That's a very good move to do you want
to be my manager.
So that is a really huge.
You got super real,
super fortunate.
That's like a crazy.
But uh,
yeah,
it,
it was recent as about two months ago at
anytime I call my stock guy,
I keep up in my position in him and I'll
call him as a,
put a little,
give me $25,000 more on,
on catapult.
And then he like handled Melissa give me
a call real quick.
Can't just text him now he just wants to
talk me through you show.
Oh,
you show you.
What about that other stock I told you
about?
You show you that stock is doing way
better now.
All right.
Hey,
let's just do.
I like catapult,
man.
Dude,
you just blew catapult the fuck up.
I liked when you just did.
I think it's a solid.
I mean,
but I,
I wouldn't,
I've told friends about it.
They like it too.
I just,
it's still early in the company and they
got offices in the states.
They based in Australia,
I think,
uh,
if I don't know what the fuck it is,
explaining it to me.
What does it mean?
Wearable GPS technology.
Now if I'm an idiot and I'm hearing
that.
Um,
okay.
So you use a satellite to track the
movement of the performance,
like heart rate,
a workload?
Yeah.
Sap,
it's all done through like what an ankle
bracelet.
Like what do you,
what do you put on them?
I think that chest.
How do you,
how do you know what the exertion is?
Is it a vest outside vest?
Is it okay?
It's a little picture of what that
means.
Oh,
this guy.
that's what you were showing me earlier.
Oh,
that's different.
Okay.
That makes sense.
This dude just got like a chest harness,
which I'm sure could measure.
I don't know,
like energy.
What would it measure?
How does something on your chest measure
what you're doing with your legs?
Like,
how do those,
uh,
iphone apps measure your strides and how
many steps you take and you can do it
off of like a,
there's a,
it's not easy math,
but they can tell how far off,
like if you're six foot and know how
long like the,
Oh,
you enter your height and the whatever
it's called.
The little interesting cycle.
Amateur,
I think of the right word.
But.
So it's not necessarily tracking you
through GPS.
This one might be,
I don't know.
This one is right?
Isn't that the premise on this one?
I mean,
how do you know how they do it in the
UFC where they're tracking how much,
how many feet they're running around the
October?
That's a good question.
They don't have a gps shit.
They probably following them with like a
tracer,
maybe a dude.
Uh,
it's his job to follow each person with
A.
I mean,
I would do that,
but you know what man,
that,
that statistic is interesting.
And I,
I,
I support the chasing of the data and
try to figure out how much someone will
be lose.
But it's not that important.
It's not that important.
Yeah,
it's weird.
It's getting super specific because it
doesn't necessarily,
uh,
it's,
it's a statistic.
It's interesting.
Just didn't dwell on it.
So these dudes that are playing soccer,
they met the,
the monitor all that too,
like how much each team runs and all
that shit.
They just in football,
they just recently,
the last couple of years stop hitting
and practice.
Not more because I found out about
concussions and whatnot,
but it's also added technology and like
when I was at cowboys training camp last
week,
there was a guy telling me they brought
an eight k cameras for when Tony Romo
was hurt so he could sit in a truck in
the back of practice and watch real time
football practice with a headset on,
like vr stuff.
Oh Wow.
Shit.
And so he could see the real
don't give advice on what was going on.
He was heard for the last eight weeks or
whatever the year and that,
they don't have it all the time because
it's really expensive to run right now
still.
But they still had three d,
three 60 cameras running around
following the players.
A crazy stuff.
Just shout out to uh,
the dude from the Dallas cowboys.
He was,
what's his name,
Charles that drives the Charles?
He hooked it up.
He gave me a car to give Jamie.
It's like,
I know Jamie's a football fan.
Let's make it happen.
Grid iron.
They're doing that for the UFC to just
trying different things out.
Three 60 video.
There's new technology will be.
There's going to be virtual reality
where you're going to be able to like be
Nick Diaz as he fights against conor
mcgregor.
You're gonna.
Be able to look through each fighters
eyes.
They're going to figure out a way to do
it.
Imagine just a little chip is needed.
What,
what shape you got Jamie?
The s 18.
Oh Man.
He should have waited for the 19.
I know,
but I'm pretty happy with the 18.
I mean it's,
it doesn't take as much battery life.
I got 363 d capability.
It's just low resolution.
It's good.
Yep.
We're good at video.
Game was pretty intense to the new UFC
game on ps and I know it sounds like I'm
plugging,
but it.
No,
it was cool.
We would yelling me and my me and my
friend was like,
God,
like it was that intense because it was,
you know,
there's parts where you almost want to
knock the guy out and then it's a good
game.
Very good game.
Have Fun.
So I,
I can attest to it because uh,
I had to do the commentary for that
game.
Yeah.
Like the,
when you hear that EA sports game,
that's not commentary from actual fights
as commentary.
Just me doing pretend and Goldberg don't
pretend and do,
we did a fuck load of ours.
Yeah.
I mean it was hours and hours and hours
and hours and it was over a long and I'm
not complaining,
I'm just saying you had to say so much
stuff.
And there's a man that scan meaning
well on a game.
Yeah.
I'm in the game.
You have to,
um,
have a secret.
I got to have a code,
like the Konami Code.
Oh,
I did this so I can get out of doing
more commentary because there was so
much to do.
Tamra wish I looked that good.
There was so much to do.
Uh,
as though it was,
it was a constant grind.
But I put my app,
my full effort into it.
Like I,
I really wanted it to be good.
Oh,
I was thinking if I was a kid and I was
playing this game,
I would want it to sound like,
like a guy really got head.
It's isn't as like we are.
Here it is,
man.
It,
it was a fun.
Is like I want to see me get beat the
fuck up.
Just Jamie.
Jamie shown a video of me about to get
my ass kicked by Nick Diaz are you get
destroyed really fast.
I would imagine if the game is
realistic,
pull it up.
I'll come and I get fucked up.
But they might have used to show secret
character.
They might have.
You got some bullshit skills.
Have you juiced up?
It doesn't matter.
I got some bullshit with bills.
Let's hear my.
Because you know,
I'm super casual fan,
so my commentary.
No.
Rather with the leg kick.
I've never heard this before.
Oh,
we're all good with the leg kicks.
Get kicked in the face.
I'll get with the cakes.
Diaz is backing it up.
Rogan missed.
Oh really?
It kicked in the chest.
Tattoos?
Accurate.
Look at that.
Holy Shit.
Oh.
Broke his neck.
Can about the high disadvantage.
Ow.
Oh ow.
World is in danger.
Let's see what rogue his ground game is
like.
Not Good.
Diaz is about the price.
Road Dog Shit off my back.
Will Rogen.
Be able to pull off a submission from
this position.
Oh,
is it?
turnaround.
It's called sweep this amount.
I let him up.
Wow.
Good.
Back Up.
Oh,
this should be illegal.
roles should be illegal.
Back in two people fake fight.
When you know one dude would beat the
fuck out of me.
No Nice had made.
So it's not.
Leave any.
Any confusion.
Oh,
this is so stupid.
We'll
he's
out.
Wait,
let me punch him in the head when he was
young.
Conscious.
Why don't they stop the fight?
Quicken a fake me rather than the fake
him out.
That feels weird,
but felt weird.
You know what bothered me the most,
the last two punches because he wasn't.
He was already unconscious.
The fake him.
Oh,
did you know hard?
Nick Diaz would fuck me up like this is
an embarrassment to humanity is allowed
to be a visual image of me.
Beat Nick Diaz is dumped all the Brian
James.
Dude.
Enjoy Shit,
man.
That's what.
That's what?
It's an escape.
This is what I want to say.
I want to see Nick Diaz versus conor
Mcgregor.
That's what I want to say.
I want to see that more than I want to
see anything in life.
I was.
I had,
so I want to say I want to see the
Aurora borealis more that I want to go
to the Keck observatory in Hawaii and
revisit the Milky Way more than I want
to see any of those things.
I want to see Nick Diaz versus.
No.
Nick Diaz.
Conor mcgregor had a cool his little
walk around or wearing as he got it.
It was awesome.
He was awesome.
He's a bad motherfucker.
Did would,
the way he walked around it would have
gotten the ring.
I didn't think he was going to get
punched in the face as much as he did
and we still won.
But that was a cocky inches.
I was like,
oh,
he bought the first round,
knock out this mother fucker.
The way he just came in here.
Well,
I mean,
what he's trying to do is just like
shake it off,
put an air out there.
But at the end of the day he's fighting
Nate Diaz.
He's no one's getting a first round
knockout,
crazy war.
He knew it.
He had to be conservative in that fight.
Energy was so crazy.
It was insane.
It was.
So.
I was so nothing ever right.
It was.
So.
I'm so glad I went to see a lot.
Oh Man.
So He.
Me Too.
So,
um,
uh,
as I,
as I said,
I'm a casual fan.
So there's a couple of times where a
kinda knocked him to the ground,
Kinda doesn't want to do ground game
with him because he was,
he was,
he would tell them to come up.
Right.
I would think normally for my lack,
not much
knowledge.
I would think once you knock somebody to
the ground,
you try to go in with those hammerfest
you could,
you could.
However,
if you do that with a guy like nate
Diaz,
he might not be hurt at all,
especially when you consider the fact
that,
uh,
he connor through a bunch of really
powerful left leg kicks and he had
fucked up nate's right leg because,
because of the fact that both southpaw,
what happens is that back leg becomes
the front leg.
So the right leg is in front,
right?
And he's just getting chewed up.
But this left power lead character right
from the beginning,
like over and over and over and over
again.
When you get hit with a bunch of,
like really powerful leg kicks like
that,
it makes it super difficult for you to
move.
Right.
You know?
And then conor just fought a smooth,
smart game plan,
you know,
he um,
he engaged from the outside where he,
his speed was an advantage and did some
damage but didn't unload himself like he
did in the first fight,
in the first fight.
He did that too.
But if any unloaded himself a nate
survived and when he survived,
Connor's gas tank was empty.
So this time connor was way more
conservative.
Yeah.
We'll see you running away a little.
But he'll run and get,
you know,
you could,
you could say it.
He got away from him.
He ran away.
But when he was on a cake,
want to get close to the kt over it and
make it more into the sense of it,
man.
It's okay.
You don't.
People are mad that he ran away.
Who wound your mood?
Because sometimes you take a break.
Sometimes you take a break.
He knows the three moments in the round.
He's got he,
he knows there's,
I mean,
I don't know when it was,
there was,
there was a couple moments in time where
he totally turned away from him.
But then he engaged.
Yeah,
he did.
It wasn't like he was running the whole.
He was just,
when he found himself in a compromising
position,
he would get out of it.
It's interesting.
It's an interesting thing to do.
You guys try to kick your ass.
I'm going to go over here for a minute.
It's something funny about it.
You know?
Seemed like a good mood.
It's the right move.
When you're.
When you don't feel like you can fight
right now.
What do you want to do?
Stand in their to get on the boys got
mom,
get in there.
If you don't feel like you can breathe,
maybe you should move away and breathe.
Otherwise some dude could punch you in
the body and you can go down.
It's like it's not a smart move to stand
in there.
If you feel tired,
how many fights do you think happened
amongst the audience members?
Because that's way less than you would
think.
I saw this girl,
she was fighting her boyfriend or
something.
I don't even know if it's a boyfriend,
but she was choking him and she was
going crazy.
He and she had walked away and she came
back to him and then,
uh,
she was blind and sorta look lightly
like Ronda Rousey.
I posted it on snapchat.
You Ronda Rousey out here tripping
and then,
uh,
and then some immigrate twitter posts.
Apparently Ronda Rousey Ronda rousey
wouldn't be running
crazy and it was a video of you don't
really see the face,
but you see security chasing some blonde
woman that is so stupid.
He apparently Hannibal spot at Ronda
Rousey.
Apparently he's the only one that's
nobody else to.
That's hilarious.
That was so stupid.
It was good time.
She's like one of the women that you
would ever want to fight like at a gas
station.
You know,
like Rhonda Rousey.
She throw you in your fucking head on
the concrete.
That's terrible.
It's terrifying.
Have women like that out there.
I could just beat your ass.
Huh?
It's terrifying.
Like it.
Whenever I'm at the UFC and somebody
gets kicked in the face,
I just always,
I just think about how disappointed I'd
be if I got kicked in the face of what
did I do in my life?
Was somebody kicking me in the face.
Even especially.
I mean you've never been kicked in the
face.
It's just been kicked in the face.
Especially like that's why I'm glad I
didn't fight that guy and I'm glad I
don't.
I don't put myself in situations where I
got to fight a strategy because you
never know where.
I'm just.
If,
if I was to be fighting,
I'm trying to throw hands poorly,
but if somebody just kicked me in the
face and be like,
oh,
I didn't,
I didn't know you would go do that.
Is Donald cerrone combination.
God Damn.
That's beautiful.
Right?
Left high kick.
Boom.
Yeah,
and they just turned his back.
That is Matrix Shit.
DOTS.
Ronnie lives in the fucking Matrix.
Do Right now at almost 70.
He's coming on the podcast next week.
Jamie,
he's here on next Tuesday.
I'm going to fucking convince him.
Live on the Internet.
Don't drop down from one 70 and one
slash 70 is a fucking wizard.
Who the hell stop and rick story like
this.
Um,
and Donald cerrone is a fucking wizard.
He's a wizard at one 70
if it felt it felt kind of barbaric or
archaic,
but when you have money on my and then
beating the shit out of somebody else
and you're winning,
it's a different type of emotion.
When he went serone started fucking that
dude up.
I stood up.
You were in there with them.
I was in there.
Isn't there with fucking couple thousand
dollars?
Hell yeah,
I was with them.
I was in fucking appreciate your
loyalty.
First of all,
it's both on it.
And Donald Cerrone,
dope.
And then a Johnson.
Uh,
I bet on Johnson right before the fight
started,
I was like,
what were the aunt?
He was minus 2:50.
So that's pretty reasonable considering
how hard he hit and he wanted so fast.
So I got on it.
We think it's.
Somebody told me I have to research it.
Please do.
Was that the fastest knockout in the
history of the light heavyweight
division?
I think it was close,
it was 13 seconds or something.
We'll all go to place.
My Bet.
He hit so hard.
That happened so fast.
It was like he hit so hard.
It happens so quick.
When glover started pressuring him,
like what?
When I score a fight or rather a
commentator fight when I watched
something like that.
And I'm like,
okay,
what can glow overdue and what can
rumble too.
We know rumble has awesome stand up
skills.
We know we had a college wrestling
background.
We know he's a really powerful and he's
probably the hardest hitter ever.
So what can we do?
He's really technical.
He can survive a storm.
Maybe he could take him down,
maybe get them into deep water.
So we start town super aggressive.
Bob and we even Tyson style and the one
haymaker one haymaker upper cut.
So third,
Ryan,
Jim.
Oh Wow.
Seven seconds.
Goddamn Ryan Chimo.
Uh,
rest in peace.
Ryan.
Jim.
Oh,
he just died recently.
I got run over by a car and Canada.
Shit.
James Irvin Sandman eight seconds.
Who did he fight?
And then John's John's.
Is that gambling to gamble on that?
And have it happened in that fast that's
like fucking craps.
They should put like a 32nd over under
on summer rumbles fights.
This is literally a 32nd because he's so
scary right now.
He's so scary.
He hits guys in a totally different way.
It's like he knows something that nobody
knows about.
How to hit people.
This dude.
What was that guy's record?
Daddy fought for Alexander.
Eight seconds.
That's right.
What was the guy?
Johnson.
False record.
Was it 25?
He was an elite fighter.
Oh,
glover is beyond elite glover's font for
the title.
He had a five round fight with Jon
Jones.
Went to the distance.
Yeah.
So one of the best fighters in the
world.
Glover's.
Excellent.
And that's crazy that he got gotten 13
seconds.
You don't what it is,
man.
There's the human frame.
You know,
like the skull,
the brain,
the neck can only take so much.
It just can only take so much.
Yeah.
And most people can't hit that bell.
You know that bell when you go to the
carnival and he slammed down on that
bell and the little thing goes up.
And
most people can't make that thing Dang
in this world.
But Rumble Johnson,
he can make that thing ding every time
with his open barrage you with is a
first,
you know,
name the number 200 punches and kicks,
whatever it is.
He can knock you the fuck out.
The question with a guy like that is,
if it gets past that 200 number and the
opponent is still there,
can you make it through it?
And that's what happened in the cormier
fight.
It's like rumble hit with everything but
the kitchen sink.
But cormier is so fucking tough.
He's so tough from being a world class
Olympic wrestler from a guy who competed
all over the world.
He's just got this.
This is like a level of toughness that
you can't recreate.
And he takes a big bomb but figures out
how to scramble and survive.
And so he makes it into law.
What rounded cormay?
Submit rumble.
See,
the thing about a guy like rumble though
is you could submit them once,
but once he figures out what you did and
he remembers how much it sucked when you
did that to him.
Can you do it again and if you can't do
it again,
what if he can figure out how to keep it
standing?
Yeah.
What if he could figure out how to keep
hitting you with those barrages of heavy
bones coming flying at you with perfect
technique.
He is so fucking hard,
man.
What third round?
Well,
cormay took them into deep water,
man.
What is comedy is such a bad
motherfucker
at?
Where does that come from?
We know that some people just naturally
fast.
Is that,
is that just a uses naturally able to
hit hardest fuck.
Or do you punch walls?
Sometimes you can close it up.
You can get better,
but it is also a natural sort of this
the reality of it.
A totally objectively,
everybody has a ceiling and you can't
pass that ceiling.
You see certain people that have certain
frames like maybe they have really
narrow shoulders and really small hands
and it really small waist.
They can't generate the same kind of
power that a guy like rumble Johnson,
Ken,
or there's a lot of other guys like guy
like rampage Jackson,
Ken,
for a guy like George St Pierre can.
There's.
There's certain like physiques,
Ilir,
Latifa.
You ever see that guy fight?
No.
Pull this motherfucker up.
I think he's fighting Ryan Bader.
I say motherfucker with all due respect
sir.
He's just tank of a wrestler and you
look at that guys frame and he just
bombs on dudes.
Knocks him unconscious,
but you look at his frame and he's
throwing punches.
Let's go.
Okay.
That's like this is.
There's levels of athletes,
right?
There's levels of wrestlers.
His levels of strikers and when you see
certain dudes,
the way they can move their body,
like you ever watched Cirque du Solei?
Yeah.
Even seeing it live,
seeing it left 70 degrees.
It is amazing.
You feel like how the fuck do they do
that with their body?
You immediately start feeling inadequate
with your body.
I mean that's why I feel I just can't.
I just get inspired by the choreography
and I said I need to step my show up.
Oh,
that's a beautiful one.
I'm going to target.
I think I want to figure out how to do a
handstand with one hand check above
being with one hand.
So this is hank.
Yeah.
So he's the light heavyweight and
heavyweight light heavyweight two.
Oh,
five.
Okay.
So the point being that a gentleman,
13 pounds less than me,
he's,
I'm a light heavyweight.
Well me and him one on one.
He weighs 200,
five for about 13 minutes,
probably goes back up to whatever it is
before he starts this cut.
But my point being like,
just like look at the size of that
motherfucker.
I mean Jesus Christ,
look at that dude.
He's a tank.
There's,
there's limitations of the human frame
and that guy has a different bone
structure than Doogie howser.
You know,
there's just no denying it.
It's or no,
that's a bad example.
But you know,
there's a lot of guys that are his size.
They just don't have the kind of
advantages that he has.
Bone structure wise,
physically like what he can do,
there's like a certain amount of
horsepower at certain guys have and you
watch that fight.
You look at that guy,
the guys,
it's a fucking tank of a man.
Brock Lesnar,
perfect example guys takes off.
How many years have you take off?
Like five years.
At least six years at least.
He fights Mark Hunt,
roids or no roids,
whatever the fuck he tested positive for
or anti estrogen blockers or whatever.
You just forget about all that.
The fact that this guy was able to fight
mark fucking hunt after five or six
years of no fighting,
just doing pro wrestling and then when
that's insane,
you know,
I had had a bed in.
I'm Mark Hunt and you had told me and I
didn't know that I told you I'm casual.
I'm a casual fan.
I took Mark Hunt but I didn't know
anything about it.
And then uh,
he walks out and I'm like,
Oh shit,
this motherfucker,
he's built like me to add a cash back.
So I did not go on in my book,
My online book.
This is before the fight stopped.
I'm trying to bet on a brock lesnar real
quick.
Oh,
that's already taken the bad data.
That was like,
Oh man,
I didn't bet on this guy that's built
like me Brock Lesnar.
See,
here's the thing though.
That's not necessarily true.
I know is that necessarily true,
but that was my instinct at the time,
like,
oh no,
what brock lesnar did in a taking down
the amount of time off and then beating
a guy like Mark Hunt,
that's so extraordinary and he's
probably never going to get the credit
that he deserves because the fact that
one,
he was a pro wrestler and then two,
he tested positive for this anti
estrogen blocker.
Whatever the fuck he took.
I don't know what happened.
Who knows?
It could've been.
He could've been easily been some
performance enhancing formula that he
bought from GNC or it could have been
something more insidious.
Whatever the fuck it was.
The fact that this guy was able to beat
Mark Hunt after all those,
that time off just shows you what an
amazing athlete he really is.
There's no way in hell that certain guys
are going to catch up to that guy if
that guy just keeps working out.
Like there's guys that like if they just
keep working out and they stay healthy
and they stay fit and they get into the
healthy and fit with no injuries,
which is like the primary.
That's just like you.
There's certain guys that you like,
you're in a,
you're in a world of shit.
If you get a guy like brock lesnar into
the ring with you and he's not her and
he's in great shape and he has no
injuries,
you're in a world of shit.
You're standing in front of a Goliath of
a man.
A guy was a struggle to die it down.
Two hundred and 65 pounds.
Yeah.
It's not fair.
What about cm punk?
Is he good?
Is he making his debut?
He's making his UFC debut,
but I have to respect that.
He did a lot of things the right way.
He went to Duke Roufus,
his camp in Minneapolis.
Milwaukee Rather.
Excuse me.
You go to right now.
There's a lot of stuff in albuquerque.
Yeah,
there's a lot.
No,
no.
He went to Milwaukee because that's
where duke is it.
What he did was he went to one of the
best gyms in the world,
the roof,
his sport.
He Dick.
I'm his brother.
I'm Rick Rufus,
who was like a world champion kickboxer
that used to be on Pka karate and then
there's Duke Roufus do group as a world
champion more tie fighter and he's
produced like a ton of worldclass
fighters like Anthony Pettis,
Sergio Pettis,
Tyron Woodley.
Does is tracking down there.
He's the new UFC welterweight champion,
so duke roufus is just like a really
high level camp and that's where cm punk
chose to move his camp and he,
he lived there for like two years.
They always been doing this training was
signed with the UFC and he just said I'm
going to do this the right way.
And he went through a full,
like a,
like a long period of training,
learning skills and working under the
tutelage of like one of the best guys in
the world.
Oh,
who the fuck knows what's going to
happen?
We really don't know.
I mean,
I have no idea what this guy can do.
I've seen him hit some pads.
I've seen some slow motion,
weird blurry videos of him sparring.
I don't know.
I mean they might be trying to shield it
for promotional purposes.
I mean,
he might've gotten really good.
He might be like,
I mean,
if the guy's willing to do that,
that's an extraordinary amount of
discipline that it takes to move to a
place.
Change your life.
Lived there for two years.
Just nothing but train.
I mean,
who the fuck knows?
But that's the big.
The big statement is who the fuck knows?
So if you go to watch him fight,
it's like you're tuning in for
essentially like a spectacle and it
might be great and it might.
I mean we,
we have to see.
He doesn't even know.
We don't know if he's ever fought.
We don't know.
No one knows.
No one knows what the fuck's gonna
happen fall with the people that either.
That's a different thing to do.
There's a big difference.
There's a big difference between
training and reality and you know,
and maybe he excels.
There's people who excel at reality
where they,
they look lackluster and training and
then they rise to the occasion of the
event and then there's other people that
are exact opposite what a practice.
Well,
and then yeah,
the anxiety of performance is real,
right?
Everybody is just.
I was,
when it was a point
during the,
a Ds,
Mcgregor fight when the crowd started
chanting,
like they were in a clench or something
in the crowded des Des des.
And I was just like,
what is he thinking right now?
Like,
what does that feel like?
This dude is in the clench is a huge
fight.
The headliners lunch streaming down his
face.
What is his pants off?
What does he feel like,
you know,
with the crowd chanting.
I'm like,
what is that like gladiators shit.
Like,
like,
does it help?
Does it,
is it distracting?
Does it hype you up as they chat?
And uh,
it's just,
uh,
it's just the,
you know,
I'm just a real good question.
It's something I'll never,
I'll never know.
And it was something.
Hopefully.
And,
and,
and you'll find out on my podcast next
week and I'm starting,
I'll be interviewing a ideas and uh,
man,
it's a good question in,
he's the only one that can answer it or
him or anyone else has experienced that.
Right?
Because you're talking about,
you know,
at this new t bumble what did,
how,
how many people isn't seat.
I think the t mobile is like 22,000 or
so.
Really?
It's a big ass place.
It's way bigger than the MGM.
I don't know about how much,
at least a few thousand dollars because
it's like,
what is it Jamie sign?
Because it is.
Yeah,
people are chanting your name.
Oh my God.
But it's not like basketball because you
just got,
you've been punched in the face a lot so
you didn't a little bit of pain.
You might be hurting that kinda tired,
you know,
it's not just you,
you,
you know,
just drop the three are soft and then
you just jogging in the clinic.
So it's like this is cool but I'm still
kind of uncomfort
maybe fires you up.
How many?
Twenty,
$20,000 for boxing and MMA.
Oh,
that's so many.
That's a lot of fucking people.
So that's approximately 5,000 more than
the MGM.
Mgm.
About 15,000.
Somewhere around there I think.
Is that why they moved them there?
Because there's more people.
It's just a different deal.
I don't know,
you know,
I just think they could sell this out to
16.
Oh Jesus.
The mgms that big.
Wow.
Oh,
so is it Mandalay bay?
That's 15.
Is that what it is?
Or is that 14?
What am I asking?
What am I fucking census taker.
You're going to stop answering
questions.
Booking agent.
What does it hold?
Wealth thousand.
Oh shit man.
Lay based.
Only 12,000.
Hmm.
Interesting.
So,
uh,
I guess the reason why they moved it was
just the UFC could sell out those places
now,
especially for this fight.
This fight was gone.
Damn button.
That was amazing.
You could,
uh,
you could have stuck a light bulb in
your mouth and it would've started
glowing.
Right?
It was electricity in the air.
I was going through our fingertips.
It was,
it was crazy,
man.
It was a good time.
That's why I decided to keep,
uh,
working for the UFC.
It's moments like that.
The Nate Diaz Mcgregor fight.
The first one was one of the in the
Misha tate.
Holly Holm fight me.
She choked Holly Holm unconscious in the
fifth round.
It was fucking chaos.
I remember thinking,
how could I stop doing this?
How could I.
I can't believe I even got this job in
the first place.
I get to watch this crazy shit and talk
about it from the.
So you wouldn't know when they bought
it.
I wasn't sure.
I just was thinking I was doing too many
things and then I decided bombs just
instead of just being crazy launch,
do less.
I'm just going to do less and doing
less.
It just made a big difference.
Vape pen use after you have a man.
He's just got punched in the face of
folks.
Relax.
Should be.
You should let him use it immediately
after it just,
let's be scientific about this.
We all want everybody to be on the same
page.
We don't want people cheating.
You know,
if this guy,
you watched him fight five rounds,
there's no more contest coming up.
Let him do something that's medically
proven to reduce inflammation.
It's not even marijuana.
It's CBD oil.
Also.
Those punches up probably way worse for
him than CBD oil.
Oh my God.
It's CBD lungs.
Good for you.
Yeah,
exactly.
Especially when you have inflammation.
Yeah,
exactly.
Should be nate diaz get punched in the
face before he used cbd.
That's a really good point,
man.
It is a really good point because for
someone to be that hypocritical that you
let a guy get punched in the head for 25
fucking minutes,
but you won't let them smoke a vape pen
because what you think is cheating is
cheating.
Death as
will stay alive.
Sadly with football,
he uh,
he was smoking marijuana.
Football.
Football is way worse for you.
Then we'd is worse for you.
And probably football is worse than
cocaine.
High hip flag football.
Yeah.
Football is probably worse for you than
most stuff.
Drinking out of ponds.
Footballs.
Fucking dangerous.
Super Dangerous Man.
But they just let it try to maintain a
good image about it.
But I don't smoke weed,
don't smoke weed,
but you might get Hella concussions,
but don't smoke weed because that
doesn't look good for because we gotta
sell this.
But like,
I love the word hello,
but I'm too old to use it.
I just turned 49.
That's what the cut off.
Just do it man.
You can say hello.
Say Hello.
You're just encouraging me to say to
tell that girl asked her what her dreams
were.
Hannibal's
you know,
you,
you pumped him up,
he pumps you up.
You're telling me as the girl with a
dream I really wanted to ask is so bad.
She had that vibe.
Man.
I see a lot of bad ones.
Her vibe was crazy and they might not
have.
And I wish I took the shot.
Yeah,
I would've helped her with her.
Whatever dreams my.
If I had,
if I could.
What do you want to do?
You want to.
I can.
I know somebody like that and you could
find some money.
If you don't know somebody finds her
mind.
You can find something.
I wanted to because she wouldn't be hard
to find somebody.
I'm going to go,
or you know what I
did,
I did think about,
I'm a,
I saw it.
Her name was on the receipt.
Google her name and uh,
the restaurant name and see if she got a
linkedin page.
Linkedin doesn't have a linkedin page.
You sound like super rare,
but hey,
she seems like a waitress were way
bigger.
Ambitious man in La or New York actually
more than Vegas.
Yeah.
It's gonna be hard because you're going
to have to take a gamble whether or not
she's still working there,
whether or not you know what day her
shifts are on Saturday,
Sunday I went back,
I was there two nights,
two afternoons.
Really stalkerish,
but we ain't say no place where you say
no
that stock was,
but I do.
I did a enjoy her energy and I would
help her.
I say go back.
I would help her in a platonic go back
in a zen way,
like completely empty to go back and
experience like sitting in her section
and uh,
you know,
just saying hi.
Yeah.
Seeing what's up but don't,
don't be like crazy about it.
I wouldn't be crazy about it,
just say,
hey,
I need this.
I need to have A.
I've been to vegas a bunch of recently
with no shelves in Vegas,
not even just to.
I've been to the past to ufc things and
then sometimes I just another trip just
to kick it to fun place.
It's a strange place.
I was just in this area outside of Reno.
It's um,
we were about five hours outside of
Reno.
We were camping and doing this,
a hunting show and uh,
it's all in the mountains and the desert
above Nevada.
It's somewhere in the area of where they
do that whole burning man thing.
Okay.
Dude,
it was amazing.
Who was,
who I was.
It's me and a bunch of a camera people
and this guy,
Steve Rinella poster show the media we
struck out,
but we were out there in the mountains
above Nevada to food.
There's a whole other world out there.
It doesn't even look real.
I can just,
it doesn't look real.
You go to this place.
There's no people.
It's just giant fucking mountains.
They go up to like a Louis.
We were at 9,000 feet.
There's other ones that go up to 11,000
feet and you're looking at these things
like,
what the fuck?
This is Nevada,
Nevada,
these fucking.
That's a picture from my instagram.
That's,
that's Nevada dude.
That's the Nevada desert.
That's the what's called the high desert
is,
like I said,
about five hours outside of Reno was
amazing.
Oh,
this was a.
This is what you,
uh,
is the hunting trip?
No.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I was there for.
I was there for a week.
It's a,
it looks crazy.
I think we could fail.
You appreciate how that looks
and I appreciate how that feels,
but I think I'm such a city dude where I
get to that.
Like,
this is beautiful.
This is cool.
I have a couple of drinks and a check
this out.
All right.
Five hours.
We good?
Let's go back to the light.
I understand.
I understand that,
but I liked the views.
However I get antsy,
but you zen out smooth.
I could get antsy too.
I think I'm what I'm trying to do.
One of the things I'm trying to do by
going to these places and disconnecting
for a few days is find out what I really
think about things where it's just me
and my thoughts and interacting with my
friends.
This is one of the good things about
doing this show.
It's called media.
This Guy Steve Rinella,
who's the host of it is like a really
smart,
really nice guy,
really interesting guy.
And um,
you know,
I like hanging out with him and all of
his crew and his friends for like all
these days.
So it's really fun.
So in doing that and having it being
really fun,
you get to relax.
Yeah.
And you get to just sit back and hang
out with these fun,
cool guys and just relax and this is
your world now.
This is your tribe,
right?
You know,
and he told me that before,
that had that sort of how he views it
like that,
it,
that it's his tribe and a cool group of
friends and that now I understand it
now.
It's like it's a,
I think that disconnecting for awhile.
Every now and then just take,
take a few days off just you don't even
have to go anywhere,
but it's probably a good idea too to
like on purpose take a few days off of
anything coming in and just let's see
how you feel about things.
Even if I'm out and about at bar or
something and my phone dies and I'm not
charging it.
I find myself having a fine.
I realized I'm a really strange person
when I talk to people when you get,
when you have to really talk to people
for awhile and it's not because now
pretty much a lot of time if you talking
to somebody is about you talking about
and then as I do
phone and so it's a break a break from
the connection
we're using and everybody.
But if you really.
I mean sometimes I mean on a date or
something,
I don't go into my shit.
So really important point.
But yeah,
if my shit's dead and I'm just out for
two hours,
I find that if I'm having long
conversations and then I started
realizing like,
Oh shit,
I'm getting kind of weird and intense
with this person.
And I started asking because I,
you know,
normally I will if I'm talking to
somebody or I'll do the bullshit regular
questions that we do,
the way you go to college,
you live here.
Uh,
when did you move from?
How long have you been doing that?
And uh,
and then,
uh,
and then you,
I mean,
at some point if you want to read,
you got to get beyond that
conversationally.
Roughly we're talking roofers right
on the same page.
Yeah,
I rufio girl.
Eliminate now what are your favorite?
See with imagination.
What are your fears?
Have you ever been hypnotized?
No.
It can be done.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I believe it.
I believe it too.
I believe in respect to all the
hypnotists out there on the road,
killing it.
Having people on stage doing goofy.
Yeah.
Have you ever seen a comedy hypnotist?
You've already seen it live at it's
crazy,
right?
Like you don't believe he used to come
to my college?
Yeah.
You don't believe it's real and then you
realize,
oh,
it is real.
It really does work.
It works.
Nobody was just do that goofy ass shit.
No,
it was just to do it.
It works in some weird way.
I don't understand it,
but I got hypnotized.
Escape.
Vinny shoreman.
He's like a mental coach.
He hypnotized me to do what is your go.
Just wanted to see if there was anything
that was holding back the way I was
thinking like in my thinking in the most
efficient and a logical way.
Am I doing the most with my time and my
not like,
do I have any hiccups that I'm not
paying attention to and the way I'm
approaching life.
So I wanted to talk to him about that.
So I wanted to see what hypnotism really
yet because I've been talking about
something that I essentially don't have
any really real understanding of.
I just say,
ah,
I saw people get hypnotized at uh,
you know,
Frank Santos comedy show and I saw that.
How did I find her?
But you know what I mean?
I found this dude,
he,
uh,
he does,
hypnotism and mental coaching for MMA
fighters.
Okay.
So,
uh,
it was interesting,
man.
It was weird.
It was like a.
When you get hypnotized,
how long is this session?
Sorry.
That's about an hour and a half.
About an hour and a half.
When,
when you get hypnotized,
you are aware that this person is
talking to you.
It's not like you're in some space
world,
but the world that you're living in with
your eyes closed in this state is a very
different world.
It's like if this person can command
your attention,
your focus for a certain amount of time,
it lets all this other stuff sort of
passed by and when the person does it
with no judgment,
just trying to understand the way you're
feeling and thinking you allow yourself
to slip in to this strange state of
mind.
That's what it is.
It's really weird.
Like it'll wake up immediately.
Like if,
uh,
if you heard like an alarm going off,
like
it's not like you're drugged,
but it's a,
I think there's a bunch of different
states of consciousness leading from the
dream world,
which we all voluntarily go into every
night when we go to sleep,
we go on,
go to sleep,
we conk out and we have dreams.
We remember them,
we remember them,
remember them all the time.
We,
you know,
you have some wacky fucking idea that
came into your head.
Didn't make any sense.
And I think there's states of
consciousness from being totally awake
fearing for your life because you're in
the middle of an earthquake to being
like drifting in and out of dreams.
You know,
where you're not sure you're there or
you're not there and you wait.
What was that?
Real?
What the fuck happened?
You know,
you're sitting in your car maybe at a
road stop.
You got a six hour drive.
You're like,
let me just pull over for an hour.
He was drifting.
You're not sure if your sleep.
Do you ever just close my eyes and just
start seeing weird as colors and shapes
and.
Shit,
not even hot.
Yeah,
but just I'll just close wise and then
like now it's nothing but certain times
it would just be weird shapes and just
different.
It's pretty cold where your brain can
make all kinds of funky chemicals man
and they don't necessarily exactly know
why.
It's not like there's a bunch of
different things that you can do to make
your brain produce certain chemicals
like in a row,
like as far as like a,
you know,
maybe you can like skip rope for 20
minutes and do 50 deep breathing
exercises and you'll get into a like a
psychedelic state.
No one's exactly sure.
Like what the fuck it is that allows
people to get to certain states and
whether or not like the way your brain
works is the same as my brain.
Definitely.
No,
it doesn't make any sense.
Why would it be like,
we all know,
like I hear people saying I can't
fucking sing at all.
I hear people saying and I hear like a
beautiful voice like we were.
We're walking by some people the other
night in Vegas when we were on our way
to go eat after the fights and then
there was a this guy and this girl,
they were saying they must have been a
part of some team or something like
that.
They might have.
It must have been some entertainers
because they were way too good and they
were saying it and they were singing
with each other and they were singing
with each other in harmony in this
hallway and everybody was like,
Holy Shit,
because they just had a sound.
They made this the exact that appeal to
everybody.
That's something my wheelhouse here,
but my.
My brain is super sensitive to when
sounds off and sometimes you go to a.
If you go to karaoke spot,
somebody doing karaoke and if they pick
the rock songs and pop songs will sort
of be the exact beats,
the hip hop songs.
The beats will have this.
It's a different version of it or it it
just and it drives me crazy.
It's certain things with music like
little shifts in music that drive me
crazy.
I hate when songs are a,
I don't like when there's acoustic
versions of gangster rap songs that
makes.
That drives me crazy sonically in
certain just musical things that just
pissed me.
It just in that,
in a.
not in a good logical.
It's just that type of thing where I'm
like,
I have to leave here.
Yesterday by Uber driver from the
airport,
which I.
He was playing his own mix tape.
He didn't say he was playing his own mix
tape,
but I could feel that he was planning on
mixtape because you played the same
music for 40.
Oh my God.
The rapper name began withK ,
his name began with Kate on Uber and it
was bad.
It was really bad hit.
The beats was already,
but he's bad.
He had no charisma on the mic and it was
just.
And so now I'm sitting here and I just
decided I was going to take this.
Just take it.
Just take how angry this is making me
because I don't want to give him the
conversation because he wants me to be
a.
He wants me to say who's this?
Anyway,
that's me.
Man.
You're really talented.
How long have you been rapping?
So I pretend I made me and him.
Um,
how long have you been rapping man?
Uh,
I've just been doing it a,
you know,
just few years,
man.
Trying to get it going.
So do you,
do you,
uh,
do you play this in the car all the time
and just listen to yourself all the
time?
Yeah,
all the time man.
Just,
you know,
especially my favorite is when it's a 40
minute rides with somebody that just got
through traveling for awhile.
Yeah.
Do how loud you playing this shit?
I'm playing man.
I'm pretty loud.
And you know what the loudest is?
A little bit less loud than that.
That's how I play it.
I feel you do this your car?
Yeah man.
Right.
You know it was one song.
The Hook was a don't do it.
I'll just get to know you're talking
about him.
What'd he say?
All black BMW.
All black BMW was the hook.
That was the word.
And the hook isn't not the melody
necessary because I didn't use any
magic,
but uh,
we wouldn't have all black BMW.
Oh,
interesting.
No Uber bars and maybe if he changed his
cars,
no lyrics or no lyrics about,
but it was just,
I was just sitting there like,
what also I get that is la and I get
that people are looking for opportunity
and trying to make it.
How about you play me
what you think your best one or two
songs is?
Oh wait a minute.
You to say one or two,
one or two you're going to be involved
in a serious conversation.
But this was swollen,
but I made right out from my grandmom's
died.
No,
it's like,
you know,
I was hanging out and I was like,
fuck this life.
So I wrote the song.
Not the bad stuff,
but I feel like that should be.
If that's what,
if that's your songs,
if that was me,
that would be my perspective on a 40
minute ride.
Hey me ask you this.
What if a guy plays you these two songs
and they're awesome and you're like,
Holy Shit,
this is really good.
Yeah.
Then we'd do what do I do?
Maybe say,
uh,
in the car and when he tweeted out like
this dude,
motherfucker,
uber drive,
ask them go fast music.
Hey.
Plus again.
Uh,
and,
and try to push that.
If it's amazing and I am and I genuinely
feel it and if it's something I want to
hear getting because that's the hallmark
of a great song for me.
If I got to keep listening to this
overdose,
frank ocean just dropped a new.
He's dropped his new album.
Finally.
There's a song solo on there and it's
just a simple Oregon plan.
He's just,
he's singing sorta saying rapping and
it's a bunch of good songs and I
haven't,
but I can leave that on.
I,
I'll listen to a song.
Yeah.
15 times in a row.
Isn't that interesting?
Yeah.
It's not a lot of things like that.
Like movies definitely aren't like that.
A comedy definitely isn't like that.
No.
But there's something about songs.
I'm certain somebody though,
some stuff with comedy with me,
certain timing moves that people do
certain bits.
I will rewind a moment.
People,
my ex girlfriend,
she might have,
she tolerated but she probably hated it.
It will be certain things like a quick,
a weird thing in a show and I would just
bring that shit back.
I will bring that,
our riding that shit.
Yeah.
10 Times.
That's what dice clay's career was kind
of built on is that people wanted to
hear the same things over and over
again.
What's in the ball bitch.
Oh,
the whole audience would be screaming
it.
It was like one of the first times where
was a firm yet.
But this type of shit,
our wine is not our wine.
Our wearing a facial expression like a
cut to and somebody's making weird and
if it's right,
if it's done well directed and with our
and that type of shit.
Just a weird line.
It was stuff off of uh,
Maria Bamford show lady dynamite moments
off of that.
It was this moment where they broke the
fourth wall with a patent Oswald talking
to her about,
uh,
doing standup on the shell.
He was playing a character.
Then he broke and then that moment was
so crazy shit like that with our just is
certain lines.
Bojack horseman has a bunch of Shit with
Algiers.
I will watch the same moment 15,
20 times just because I just think that
little part is fun.
In the same with rap songs and certain
rap songs where there'll be a 22nd 32nd
piece.
Yeah.
With the dude is just wrapping his ass
off and I'll just,
I'll listen to that for five,
10 minutes straight.
Just like that part.
I still,
I still like the whole salt,
but it's a part of it.
Yeah.
The drop the drop on father stretch my
hands by Kanye West.
Uh,
the,
the buildup to that,
it's a,
it's just,
you know,
he sampled this Gospel Song with the
same side of father stretch my hands and
then there's the sample by future way.
Like,
well if your mentor don't trust you and
it drops in,
that's what I walk in.
Like it's a crazy and I'll just listen
to that if I'm driving around.
I just listened to that first part like
five times and there's a certain.
I just like,
I don't know.
Is that like a
normal thing?
Hunter Thompson used to do that.
When he used to write,
he used to listen to the same song,
like candle in the wind.
He was still like Elton John Candle in
the wind.
There's a video of him doing that.
He's sitting in front of the typewriter
and he's just writing in the same songs,
playing over and over again out of loop.
I've tried it before too.
I flew from New York to La writing the
entire way,
listening to crazy train by Ozzy Osborne
cable was out of this shit.
I want to know.
I was like in a groove,
you know,
I don't remember what I came up with,
but I remember feeling like because the
song,
I knew what the lyrics were.
It almost became like a sort of hypnosis
zone.
Five hours of the same lyrics over and
over and over.
The whole five hours.
I just listened to crazy train and I
typed up,
had some coffee,
took a leak,
which I got to do right now.
Bad.
My second podcast in a row.
I want to keep going with you,
but I got to Piss so bad james.
Ask them questions to animal.
Going back.
I'm just going to freestyle rap.
Hey,
you know what it is?
Nobody wants that.
Am I hit live now by myself?
I could do anything.
I want to hit a.
You see how my voice changes when this,
when he leave,
when he leaves,
it becomes the real meat.
We're here live on the Joe Rogan
experience.
You know what it is?
We got bottled water.
We got James said,
we got a God damn clock.
We got an o to pot figuring.
We got a biggie figurine and that lady
and we.
Yeah,
I'm going on tour.
Everybody on the Hannibal Montana Bull
experience.
I'm coming towards your city unless
you're city is Oklahoma City A.
isn't that on there,
but I will come there.
I was there.
I've been there before.
It has been good.
How long have we been talking?
Been talking a long ass time.
Two hours deep.
So check me out on tour.
Hannah Montana will experience come
through because if you don't come
through it's going to be embarrassing
for me and my family also.
I uh,
bought a building and the mortgage is a,
is crazy.
I'm kidding.
I bought it cash.
Don't worry about me.
So,
uh,
yeah,
check me out on tour and I hope you're
having a good time.
This is weird man,
because it feels like I feel so
connected but disconnected right now
because these cameras alive.
Joe's back,
Joe.
I think I owe it.
Got Weird man.
I him,
he gets weird.
He'll get what?
He didn't get.
Weird exam.
He was very weird.
I got weird.
My voice changed.
So bad to podcast is just no Bueno.
I said I just got live.
It was with no it totally top 40 Dj.
No,
that's.
I was like,
what's up y'all is Hannibal.
You know what it is?
It was just,
it was weird,
man.
My whole personality changed just
because you left.
I was like,
Oh shit.
Pardon me?
Takes that as a compliment that you're
so comfortable.
You can be yourself when you hear.
Yeah.
It was just.
It was more just.
I don't even know that.
Yeah,
it's just.
I just get hyped up.
I didn't say anything of substance
either.
I could have given 100 of my 800
podcasts.
I could have a $800 is a lot more than I
think it's like,
what is this one says?
Eight 36 could have given some good
advice.
I could have just,
you know,
talked about my mistakes instead I just
plugged tour dates.
That's a good move.
That's the right move plug pto date.
People need to see you anyway and it's a
Hannibal Montana Bowl.
The Hannibal Montana blue experience,
and if they just Google Hannibal
Montana,
double goal.
My goal,
my twitter go on facebook,
a
new instagram thing where you could take
like a video of your day.
You do all the stories.
I got to get a young person around me
all the time.
I can do it,
but I don't wanna I don't wanna do that.
I get the value of doing that.
I understand,
but I don't want to.
It's the same for the same reason.
Different,
uh,
different,
different things that I didn't get
pokemon go.
Oh yeah.
Because it sounded.
It sounds fun.
And what?
A friend of mine,
she had it on her phone and I messed up.
This is fun,
but I don't want to be on my phone that
much.
So I just got to have a,
some internet savvy.
Twenty five year old around me all the
time.
Mr Burns test be.
I said.
Oh Shit.
I just said Internet savvy.
Twenty five year old.
No,
I hope.
Make it a.
What if she was so hot and you like,
we can work this out so hot.
Nope.
Little ridiculous cartoon.
Tiny waist in the ass.
Like a fucking box of chocolates.
Heart-Shaped Valentine's Day.
Box of chocolate.
What kind of assets that Jason does not
fair dishonor avenue.
Describe to someone an unfair recently
and she's cool.
She's likes.
She's like,
Hannibal,
I don't give a fuck baby.
I don't give a fuck.
I'm not here for long time.
I'm here for good time and you're like,
let's do this.
What are you talking about?
He told my,
my employee and longtime good sap.
You gotta keep it.
Yeah.
Who Tonic plutonic.
You got to keep it all.
Work oriented.
Some work oriented is 10 sessions.
Times Professional.
Yeah.
Well,
it's weird seat.
The idea of people working alongside
each other day in day out,
men and women,
all group together in these boxes is
entirely unnatural.
When people would be around each other
in the wild,
they would do it because they liked each
other.
I am completely back in his day.
Did I never lived in.
Yeah.
My obsession is in the genetic
propensity that we have inherited from
these people and I think that in the
wild,
men and women never like grouped up
together.
They didn't like each other but in work
they do and it creates this weird
tension
where management proved themselves and
women are trying to prove themselves and
no group pond back there.
It's all about growth.
It's groupon now,
man.
And you,
you,
you didn't get lucky back then.
Like back then you just decided you're
going to hang out with certain people
and the other ones who killed.
Yeah,
right back there.
It was no waiting it out.
Now there's no way to know.
Just waited it out late night and just
hung out at the bar and in some got
popping those,
none of that.
It was just either she liked you because
you were just strong and you brought
food and killed it.
You see them like you at out.
You develop the first catapult tall
towards the enemy or you will.
Small Dude that she didn't pay attention
to and then out of nowhere out of an act
of jealousy and stepping up,
you killed the big dude and he is small,
but I guess he's the Alpha now climbed
on top of his neck and took out a conch
shell.
Now you just find something you're good
at and the cliffs,
the people in the fucking boats,
they let their torches up.
You find something you're good at and
you work hard and you can get women from
net.
This trick shot pool players didn't get
Hella Pussy.
Damn.
That should be another meme trick shot
pool players.
Hello Pussy.
There's a world where everybody mouth
there is for sure.
Well,
there was always like a pool player
groupies that would,
uh,
girls who were really good at pool.
That would date dudes that were really
good at pool.
Yeah.
But dudes that really good.
Could it pool?
They think it will translate.
Nah,
it's not even that man put the ball in
that hole that he could put his balls
and weighted balls.
Shit all talk.
But I think a couple of my podcasts ball
talk by Hannah Ball.
I like it.
I am starting a podcast.
Are you for real?
Yeah.
Would I be on it?
Of course.
It's going to be a road podcast and
we'll see if that continues.
Let's do a gig together.
Let's do a get together
on this tour that's.
Do a gig together.
Tell me when.
Man,
let's hop in.
Let's start with Kalamazoo,
Michigan.
Holy Shit.
Listen man,
I would be very happy to do a Gig with
you.
We have a lot of time.
A lot of good times.
Yeah.
You know,
man,
it's one of the crazy things about the
comedy store is that we all get to hang
out together.
We're,
we never would really work together that
much in real life.
Like if you go on the road,
you take a dude with you to open,
you know,
everywhere we go,
we take people with us to open or we
have a local guy that we know we have
come on,
we never get to be all together.
You can go to the comedy store any
night.
It'd be like you and D as in Burger and
res is.
There's no place like that.
Man.
It's fun,
man.
I love watching Rose Battle,
the comedy store.
It's the greatest thing ever.
I love.
It's just a,
the energy in that
room.
[inaudible] little ass belly.
Rome hunted some people.
It's packed in there.
They got to keep it in that fucking room
to fight it off.
Just fight it off.
No matter what they say about that main
room.
Togo in there,
that's not the place.
It's not.
It's not the place for it.
I mean,
I went to the TV taping in Montreal.
Oh,
you got some feelings about it.
How did you feel about it?
I just feel about it.
I felt good about it.
I enjoy it.
I mean,
I enjoy.
I'm also biased because I've seen it.
I think my first time there was maybe
two years ago,
right close to that in the belly room.
So,
and,
and I've seen even within the belly
room,
different things they've done to the
show in that just different things with
the djs are with the wave,
with the,
with uh,
with the racist over there and tweaks
that they've made in there to make the
show work.
And so to see something that you've been
to a bunch of times in this small space
and then see it,
you know,
be in the beat in the same spot,
watching it live.
It's,
it's cool to see something like that,
to see that type of progression.
It felt,
it felt amazing,
man.
Just tell her mine,
I like it better now.
Do Madison Square Garden.
But yeah,
the space always has to be to be right
in this,
uh,
it's uh,
it's different.
That was like a motivational speech for
expanding your theater side.
Yeah,
that was really strong.
He was,
it is.
So it was just,
it was cool to see that.
And it was.
Yeah.
I don't think I've had the,
I've seen that with a comedians or
friends of mine,
that type of progression from,
you know,
over Micah to middle atrophy,
Jack to somebody,
you know,
being on shows and being famous,
but I never saw that with.
I can't think of.
I saw that with a show concept.
Maybe have a couple,
but just something I attended regularly
to see it go from a live show and go
there and enjoy it as a live show and
then,
you know,
have it be live on comedy central.
That was something cool.
I enjoy watching that now.
I was really happy for them.
Yeah.
No,
I,
I completely agree.
All jokes aside,
I mean,
I think,
uh,
what they've managed to do by getting
that show on the air,
it's pretty monumental because there's a
god damn brutal show,
right?
Yeah.
What's the devil webpage up to comedy
central website.
They have a webpage for that show.
Are they going to do a bunch of them?
I think they're going to do it again.
[inaudible] dot com slash heroes.
But we see it.
Can I see what the page looks like?
Who's the champion?
Michael Lawrence.
Mark Lawrence.
You know my,
um,
yeah,
I know him from the store.
I've seen them around.
Great.
He's super funny.
Super great writer to have all four
episodes up for free.
You don't even have to have scroll down
a little bit.
Go in and have
the bracket.
Yep.
Now how many different hosts are they
going to have?
What are they going to do for
the host is always is Jeff Ross
and uh,
yeah.
Brian Moses.
Moses who is awesome by the way.
Probably Moses.
I'm so happy for that dude.
He such a good dude so they're not gonna
fuck with it.
So it's gonna basically be in the same
state that it's always been in sort of
racist.
They can have the racist.
See,
here's my only feeling.
This is my only feeling.
I don't have a problem with them doing.
I don't have a problem with anything,
but I wouldn't suggest them filming
those shows.
I would suggest them doing those shows
at filming.
The family room shows there is a.
there's a world in that room when when
someone's killing,
like when earl came out for that rose
paddle thing and just destroyed.
Remember that night he came out with a
fur coat on?
We did you see that on comedy central?
Do they filmed it and it was.
It was a magic because there's 90 people
in there and they smushed slight scar
sardines packed.
It's a vibe in the EU,
you everything has to be in line when
you're killing,
there's a frequency you have to hit and
earl was just on that frequency and when
you see someone do something like that
in a small room,
you realize that's the value of the
smaller room.
Yeah.
What a small room is.
Is that.
Yeah,
yeah,
yes.
This is a video of those guys,
but when,
when you're in a small [inaudible],
when you're in a small room like that
and you just let it all hang out,
there's a weird fucking energy that
there's a weird connection to that.
It's different than anything else.
It's way different than a big place,
like a big place as nice.
It's beautiful to be there.
It's cool to be a part of like 10,000
people came to see Rose Battle.
Yay.
So,
but the best show is that 90 seat belly
room or 80 seat,
whatever the fuck it is.
Fire codes.
One of the best jokes I've heard there,
I was,
I could remember this comedian's name,
but it's Ah,
you know,
you have a,
a joke does new.
That sounds like it's from the fifties
or sixties.
They just instructure and brevity.
This,
uh,
this guy,
he says that his girl,
he says she's in an on and off
relationship.
Whatever boyfriend is on when he sees
her body off when he sees her face.
Oh Shit.
I like that you.
Because I'm like,
that sounds like.
It sounds like you heard it before,
but you didn't.
I haven't heard it before.
No,
I never heard it before,
but it's short.
I sound like I sound like some old shit.
Your uncle would say we never.
That was a fucking.
You know what I mean?
I've heard many great jokes that.
But that one just stuck in my head.
They just found the eighth ever.
Tyrannosaurus rex skull in Montana.
That's right up there with that.
People find sometimes and like,
why
has no one found this skull?
They just didn't know when I saw that
combination of words.
That's perfect.
Uh,
meanwhile there's some dude right now in
the midwest screaming.
That's my big,
big motherfucking bed going crazy.
Somebody might've come up with that and
we don't even know.
We just never heard it.
They might be an open mic or that
might've come up with it three solid
weeks ago.
Might've put it on youtube.
We might be fucked here these days.
Man.
I saw a bunch of Ryan lochte.
T jokes.
Yeah.
That dude's name.
Take the same joke over and over and
over again.
It's.
I was on twitter getting robbed.
Yeah,
about him lying.
Yeah.
Like now it'd be a good time to rob
them.
I saw that.
Like for like everybody,
everybody would think that.
Did anybody do jokes about getting his
sponsorships?
Endorsement deals that seemed like
either get dropped.
They dropped,
they dropped a bunch of them today and
so part of me that he won for a body
hair removal one.
Wait a minute.
Okay,
so they look them for people.
So shout out to speed up speed speedo.
First of all,
speedo.
Hey everybody that wants to wait.
Your Shit isn't in great shape.
So how about you look at me.
Animal Birds.
That's a good point.
Successful Samsung representative also
got some other stuff coming up.
That's where a lot of things,
many irons in the fire.
I have a horrible lifestyle.
Horrible health,
great skin.
I look great on camera.
Good smile.
Speedo.
People like me.
I let people in the eyes when I talked
to them and shake their hands and I
always look in the eyes when I do shots
towards neon orange,
speedo speedos.
Who else did Ryan lochte?
They lose anybody else to run like the
law.
Also,
first of all,
I've been in Brazil.
Never had a problem.
First of all,
he shouldn't have lied about that.
It would seem like something he didn't
need to lie about De.
Also fuck swimmers being celebrated like
that.
Oh,
I like it.
That just celebrated.
Knows.
I wish to like walkers would be
celebrated.
I wish we could figure out what is
walking.
Who can walk the fastest Walker,
who can celebrate it all?
Stay alive.
Who's swimming?
We could have a hold her breath or
Olympics where people hold their breath
the longest.
Let's do that too.
To have like a swimming.
It's too many strokes to throw rocks.
It's too many strokes.
The furthest row strokes I respect.
I respect this.
Whatever.
This is the regular.
I respect this.
What is the regular.
I don't even know what it's prevalent,
but when you get into this freestyle,
when you get into this,
I can't fuck with the.
Okay.
For the people that are just listening
regular as you're throwing your arms
over the head like you see in the.
When you're doing your shoulders with
the goofy shit and swimming like that.
The the fly struck the breast stroke,
breast stroke.
Nobody cares that Michael Phelps got 22
gold medals.
Yeah,
but a buzzard of we're swimming like a
goofy ass hole that nobody slips.
Like get Outta here.
He's not the greatest Olympian.
He's swims and water.
Damn,
that's a good point.
That here's what the good point.
Someone shit themselves.
How many times you got to swim away from
danger.
One of the walkers shit themselves.
How often do you have to swim away from
danger?
You might save a couple of laps.
Usain bolt,
he goes save some lives.
He can run fast in there.
I got I got out or somebody is attacking
them.
I'm out of him.
You're saying but.
But you,
you,
you usually not around water like that
to get away from danger.
Hm.
Well,
here's the point,
like why so many strokes?
Why limit the way you move?
Like if you're going to swim,
like why do you have to swim at a very
specific way?
If this breast stroke thing was so
fucking good,
would it be the fastest way to do this?
Why don't we.
Let's.
Let's pretend.
Let's pretend this is the only shitty
way we know how to swim.
Let's just fucking throw our arms in
front of ourselves like we're part in
the curtains,
like those beads at the porno section of
the video store before there were dvrs
and and dvds and you.
Pardon
how those days,
they going to have the fucking breast
stroke.
They don't have this stroke.
If they don't have this,
then why not just have a fucking Olympic
competition where you just run,
but you hide me and the whole time too.
Very good.
Passionate.
Let's have backwards running.
If you've got the backstroke wise,
there's no backwards running in the
Olympics
from now on,
we should call that that move the porn
section.
That is you partying.
The beads that are hanging.
I bet when they fucking.
When when video games went under or
excuse me,
a videos video rentals went under.
I bet the bead industry dropped
substantially.
I've been a big part of their profits
was beating off the porn sections.
I'm dating myself here,
but you guys don't even understand.
You guys are both young guns.
When I was a boy,
when I was a boy,
you could rent videos and you could rent
porn videos.
That's how I going go to the get drunk
and leave for me for one minute.
Drunkenly Oh,
when I was kid,
Hannibal burress can't handle his
bladder.
I guess
I hung in there.
Folks.
I did my best,
but Louis Theroux during that podcast
with him for three hours and then I have
some water,
like an asshole in between.
Couldn't hang in there folks.
I'm so sorry.
What?
We're just talking about Jamie.
Were you paying attention?
What?
God dammit.
Olympics.
Swimming.
Well,
limiting your movement.
Is it ridiculous?
Like the idea that someone's going to
say,
okay,
you can swim,
but he can't swim at your best.
Swimming some goofy way.
That's not efficient.
Go ahead.
Try that.
Because if somebody could just do breast
stroke only versus a freestyle swimmer,
they would never win.
Right?
Yeah,
no way.
Right?
Why?
Mostly Olympic events.
Our events that we're looking at.
Any way I'm confused.
Well,
I'm a super big fan of curling,
so I'm gonna tell you to fuck off.
Right?
You
ever watch that,
like the panel will you ever see curling
and years ago and everyone else got
excited about it?
The Winter Olympic sport.
I was in a,
I think it was newfoundland,
new found land,
Newfoundland for Gig.
Yeah.
Great time.
Nice people when long time ago.
Yeah,
no them for killed back Newfoundland
recently to do it.
I would totally do it.
Oh,
why haven't you done it to do weird
shit.
It's been.
There's only a certain amount of your
agents is filled up very quickly with
metropolis areas.
Have you been an ambassador for UFC
Newfoundland?
Point being.
I tried erroneously to make fun of
curling while I was in newfoundland
because the,
the,
the stage always the place we were at
how all these photos with people
curling.
So the dude with the broom and the dude
with the fucking hockey,
the giant steroid it out.
Hockey puck there.
Slide across the ground.
It's so good for you.
So you try to run this meaning that
tried joking around about it and they
will not win it.
Oh,
oh.
They loved it.
They loved their curling.
So yeah,
I don't understand it,
but I guess I don't have to.
You don't have to.
They like it.
So as Newfoundland and we should go to
the loo while you watch it for like an
hour.
So you kind of get compelled,
like who the fuck's gonna win this
thing?
Yeah,
stupid.
That's booking gigs was baseball.
Let's do it.
Let's do Newfoundland.
Okay.
I'm in,
but you know you're black,
right?
This man.
Just kidding.
It's Canada.
Are they the nicest people on the earth
or is it like Swedish people?
If you ever been Sweden said that they
met the nicest people.
I think it's like the same way
sometimes.
Sometimes it's southern hospitality.
It is.
Sometimes it's southern passive
aggressiveness and they just talk
horribly behind your back.
Right.
And that's like,
um.
Well I was talking about this with
somebody recently that like,
try to imagine the fact that 18,
65 when slavery was abolished was less
than 200 years ago.
Trying to imagine what 200 years is
because it's only two lifetimes.
Yeah.
Two people being alive from birth to
death.
That's 200 years.
So these people who are very healthy
people,
very healthy,
very lucky people.
I mean,
so they're stuck in this probably net
slaves,
slaves.
I live in the beat conditions aren't
that exact,
right?
You don't have access to the,
to anything.
So it doesn't have the gluten free or to
the slave.
Slaves aren't getting the fresh pressed
juice soda,
you know,
let's,
let's cut it to maybe 60 slash 70.
His foot slaves.
Yeah.
If you're super lucky and that is only a
short amount of time ago and no one
understands that today.
There's no we,
we,
we can intellectualize it,
we can think about it,
we can put it into our heads and try to
figure it out.
No one could figure that out today.
And those,
there's a lot of those areas of the
country that are just poisoned by those
old stupid ideas.
There's just stuck in there,
man.
Yeah.
In areas of the world,
there's a lot of weird areas of the
world that is poisoned by old stupid
ideas.
I um,
I think we should do newfoundland.
Fuck.
Yes.
I think we just shake off that shit.
And Joe Rogan,
Newfoundland,
Newfoundland.
Good.
Let's do another one somewhere else.
Like Saskatchewan,
Saskatchewan.
I used to sketch one in January when I
get crazy.
I met A.
I met some Canadian.
I was in when I was in Minneapolis and
they were like,
you need.
I think they might've been functional.
Scattered while I didn't even like you
need to cut because they worked,
but it was some tourism fencing or
something.
You need to come to the Saskatchewan.
Edmonton.
I've done.
I think that I'm due to do an Edmonton
or Calgary on this tour to the river
cree and the Edmonton.
The casino.
That is fantastic.
That it's fun man.
That's how fun fucking place.
I like Edmonton,
man.
They're good people.
They're just stuck in some weird spot
that's like really cold for like four
months of the year.
But it's money,
right?
It's money.
So you got these people?
No,
sometimes no.
They just come out of high school and
make six figures.
Yeah,
with their Canadian too.
There's something about Canadians,
like their culture does not support
this.
Like,
uh,
the world domination idea that United
States sort of has ingrained in us like
we're the police of the world for good
or for bad.
Right?
It's a lot of people think mostly bad
yet,
right?
If the Canadians don't have this,
they're not just trying to create a good
life for themselves.
Yeah,
they're just people and uh,
there's a real value in that.
But there's also like this idea that the
only way Canada would exist is if the
United States is below it.
Tacting it because this is such a
fucking gangster.
Yeah.
Right.
So that's the idea that I think makes
total sense if you're looking at it
objectively.
But goddamn it makes for some Nice folks
because Canada that they're like,
I think maybe my all time favorite
people anywhere.
I think that the nicest people,
those shows that I was drawing numbers
in Canada.
Good spots at 300,
400 seat spots easily before I was doing
it over here.
That makes sense.
Even Vancouver,
I remember doing shows in Vancouver,
2011 and Toronto played the Horseshoe in
2011 and then coming through first time
just with like light credits and then
getting it.
Holy Shit.
Then they come in to fuck with me.
I couldn't.
I first started doing it.
You start hitting some splicing.
What the fuck?
I got people here.
Yeah,
and that's what Canada was when I
started getting offers to help.
I was thinking what is.
It wasn't big money,
but it was just
to have that.
It was Vancouver.
I forget the promoter's name,
but I played maybe there.
Rick Shaw,
a horseshoe tavern in Toronto if five
years ago and just be as shocked that it
was that many people that it was
psyched.
It was,
it was,
it was just,
it was.
It happened earlier over there,
man.
You know you gotta do in Toronto was me
there.
You've got to do the weed shop.
What's that?
We chopped show ever showed it,
right?
They have a front room where they sell
bongs,
rolling papers and share,
and then you go in the back room and the
back room doesn't have any error.
It's all just pot smoke.
You're breathing in pot smoke.
There's no air,
there's no air left.
The light,
the candles,
candles on the table.
They're all running on pot smoke and
promises.
There's no fucking era.
That room,
man,
it's all just pot smoke and you get high
before you go onstage and then you go on
stage and it's preposterous.
Everybody in a goddamn coma,
it is train.
Just comedy show you've ever done.
Nobody wants to have.
For me,
this is what you need to do your regular
show first and then head over to that
place around 12:30 AM.
He knew what I'm into because I do.
I like thc capsules.
Me Too,
and if it's because they met them
because I get.
I get so weird and in my head sometimes
I can't unless I'm on,
unless I'm a little drunk or a little on
something else.
I'm not able to enjoy myself high a lot,
especially if I'm in a situation where a
recognizable and people recognize if I'm
high on weed and people recognize me,
you're worried about.
I get weird.
It the fuck out.
It's understandable.
Billows my I will.
I'm like,
what am I doing?
What is life?
What choose whatever.
What's going on?
What do these people,
why are they talking to me?
Why did I do this?
What did I do this?
Do I just get.
If I'm high,
I'm gonna have.
I just can't handle it.
We need to hang out more.
Sure.
Definitely,
but it isn't a CIC capsules.
I'm going to hold your hand.
Figurative
CC capsules.
I took.
I went to a dispensary.
Shout out to native roots in Denver and
a smooth on that.
Also maybe I think I.
I think maybe the way I smoke,
I shouldn't be out in about smoking is
a.
It should be just chilling,
watching some shit,
playing some video games,
but my weed smoking never.
I just never put it.
If I can't create a situation with
nobody can talk to me,
then that's how I need to be high or the
capsules,
the capsules.
I can talk to me a capsule,
smooth me out and I started taking out
this shit is shit is great and I feel
good and I feel I can stand up on them.
I
can't do smoke weed and do standup,
but I can take a capsule and behind the
stand.
Hm.
Um,
do you know the difference between
eating and smoking it
slightly,
but I'm ready for this is a chemical
differences,
like a smell good.
It's thc.
You eat it.
That would.
The compound of the marijuana is
processed by your liver produces
something called 11 hydroxy metabolite.
Okay.
It's way more psychoactive.
It's like four to five times more
psychoactive than thc.
So you're talking about the capsules now
I'm talking about anytime you eat it,
eat it.
I don't like edibles.
If you're taking a capsule,
you're eating it.
You know what I'm saying?
But it doesn't,
it doesn't matter.
It's like if it's.
If it goes through your digestive tract
and it's processed by your liver,
takes a little bit about an hour or so,
depending upon the dosage and how strong
it is in,
you know,
whether you have a full stomach or.
Yes,
probably probably has something to do
with it,
but when it's processed by your liver,
it produces this weird psychoed
psychedelic drug.
It's very different than just regular.
I don't know if it was a reason.
The capsules I feel wasteful the than
just swollen somebody's joint.
Do you know how many milligrams are in
those capsules?
I think is is 10.
Oh,
that's good.
That's a really reasonable dose and
that's the good news about marijuana,
like medical marijuana going nationwide
as you can take a reasonable dose,
10 milligrams and it's therapeutic for
your body.
Feels good.
You relax.
Nobody gets hurt.
Somebody to explain it to you.
What?
What it.
That's what I mean.
I wish I bought way more in Denver and
also if you can just mill,
I'll see you Monday.
We'll hook you up.
Relax.
Don't say anymore to give you.
You're going to get catfished by a cop.
Bad Cop.
Yeah,
they're gonna,
they're gonna do of those one book and
you're going to be fake cops and was
like,
this dude's fucking Weirdo was going to
be a girl with a tiny waist.
Wastes like my wrist.
Yeah.
They don't like to do stuff like an
explosion given people they met awful.
They just want to fuck.
They ain't had thought.
Maybe that's a good point.
Good point.
That's hard.
I have a friendly,
thoughtful women aren't classically
beautiful.
Wow.
Believe you said that really hurts that.
No,
not a uh,
one online.
Thinking about my mom right now online.
As far as somebody who's going to reach
out to you that now the model is not
going to reach out to you.
Hey,
what do you need that shit?
Do you need something?
Model Chick reach out and say,
Hey,
you want to hang out?
But nobody's going to reach out like a
model check is not reaching out.
Hey,
I got this asshole two fingers in the
pussy grabbing like a fucking bowling
ball.
No.
Yeah.
They're not going to say,
hey,
you need this and when you,
when you,
they want to hang out,
right?
Yeah,
they know.
Say,
Hey,
you need a restaurant recommendations.
Just good point.
You know they used to
all the attention anyway,
so he's just saying,
oh yeah,
that's a good point.
Yeah.
They just,
they want to test the waters a handle.
Burse ain't playing games ladies.
Okay.
Unless you're ready to go to def con
four.
You Ready?
I got high standards mean to what
I think I want kids,
man.
Do you know what age when you have your
third or fourth hotel or they don't want
kids?
It's three years.
Two to three years.
That's a good move.
I saw this pregnant woman on the l train
in New York,
but she was one.
She was one of those was she didn't.
She just looked like her stomach was
bigger.
It nothing else affect like perfect
makeup.
Just dressed nice in a nice dress.
She had to have a wedding ring.
I want it to.
I just wanted to ask her if everything
was okay if she was with a dude,
like she was so beautiful.
I kept looking at it.
I know she felt me looking at it.
I probably wit her out.
She was so beautiful.
I started picturing myself arguing with
the real father.
Five years from now,
I started pitching myself on the train,
holding hands or there
pitzer myself.
Five years from now at the yelling at
this dude outside the house in Jersey.
Hey Dude,
you had your chance.
You can use a sperm donor.
You're looking at her beautiful real
dot.
I'm the real dad.
You calculating the potential for future
joy,
being with that person with perfect bone
structure,
you will them to take a chance and put
your whole life into air and just like,
oh my God,
look at it was you okay?
Hey Baby,
you okay?
That's what I was saying.
Okay,
well we'd say I'm her here.
Go ahead.
If I'm looking down,
I'm just shaking my head.
I'm just like,
every now and then I just go like this
with my hands.
You want to try it?
Come on the train.
Hey,
good though,
dude.
I know.
I look good.
See,
this is.
I wouldn't even if you go on a train,
if I don't have anything organic like I
was,
something crazy happened.
Whoa dude.
I'm not asking for real life.
This isn't law and order.
I know this is like.
Come on.
All right.
Okay.
I'm the girl.
Ready?
Go.
Sorry.
I just accidentally put my face in your
it.
Oh,
who's baby is that in?
This?
Is he in the baby's life?
Do you preach a long life?
Hi,
I'm financially stable.
Not quite a Mosley,
but I'm getting there.
And on that note,
ladies and gentleman,
this podcast is a wrap accountable
Montana.
Go to handle this on twitter or Hannibal
buress.com.
[inaudible] DOT com.
Yeah.
Check me out on tour.
Hannibal Montana Bowl experience.
Come through segment.
I'll be on the road and we're going to
do a new Finland.
Sit on it.
We're going to make this shit happen.
Alright.
Thank you so much.
That we can find out.
Fine.